Hoffnung sowie sowie die Beratung
weiterer Vorlagen zur wärmewende im
Gebäudebereich
über den Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung sowie über die
Beschlussempfehlung des
Rechtsausschusses zu dem Antrag der
Fraktion DIE LINKE werden wir später
namentlich abstimmen
zudem Gesetzentwurf der Bundesregierung
liegen ein Entschließungsantrag der
Fraktion der AFD sowie ein
Entschließungsantrag der Fraktion Die
Linke vor
für die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von
68 Minuten beschlossen
ich eröffne damit die Aussprache
und das Wort hat für Bündnis 90 die
Grünen die Kollegin Katharina Tröger
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich bin extrem
froh über den heutigen Tag wir treffen
heute eine enorm wichtige Entscheidung
ein Riesenschritt für den Klimaschutz
und gleichzeitig eine enorm wichtige
Entscheidung für mehr soziale Sicherheit
in diesem Land mit dieser Novelle des
Gebäude Energiegesetzes
mit dieser Novelle beschließen wir einen
konkreten Fahrplan dafür wie
klimaneutrales heizen in Zukunft überall
in Deutschland gelingen wird Bürgerinnen
und Bürger Handwerker und Kommunen
können sich jetzt ganz konkret darauf
einstellen wie dieser Weg in Zukunft
aussehen wird zuverlässig planbar und
für alle bezahlbar
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
bin sehr froh dass wir uns darauf geeint
haben dass dieser Weg ein sozialer weg
sein wird mit einer Förderung von bis zu
70 Prozent der Kosten besonders für
diejenigen Menschen mit dem geringen
Einkommen sichern wir das gerade
diejenigen geschützt werden vor den
hohen fossilen Preisen der Zukunft und
das ist die wichtige soziale
Entscheidung die wir mit diesem Gesetz
treffen
wir sichern mit dieser hohen Förderung
das schon jetzt die Entscheidung für
eine klimafreundliche Heizung in fast
allen Fällen wirtschaftlicher ist als
die Entscheidung für eine alte fossile
Heizung und damit wollen wir die
Menschen teilhaben lassen und wir wollen
sie ehrlich gesagt auch begeistern am
Ende genauso begeistern wie für die
Energiewende wo die Leute sich freuen
und Mitmachen mit eigenen Balkon
Kraftwerken wo sie toll Teil von
bürgerenergiegenossenschaften werden
genauso wollen wir Sie begeistern in
Zukunft auch Teil einer grünen
wärmewende zu werden und das können Sie
jetzt weil wir das ganze finanziell so
machen dass auch wirklich alle mitmachen
können wir haben gleichzeitig einen
pragmatischen Weg gewählt denn die neuen
Regeln richten sich nur an diejenigen
die sich sowieso für eine neue Heizung
entscheiden nur die werden mit diesem
Gesetz adressiert und wir stellen die
Planung der Kommunen in den Mittelpunkt
das heißt diejenigen vor Ort die am
besten wissen was dort funktioniert und
was nicht die werden jetzt die
wärmeplanungen entscheiden wir haben uns
gleichzeitig auf einen technologieoffen
den Weg verständigt alle Formen
klimafreundlichen Heizens werden in
Zukunft auch möglich sein und
wir schaffen mit diesem Gesetz
Sicherheit
für die Heizungshersteller die jetzt
schon in den Ausbau neuer
Produktionskapazitäten investieren
Sicherheit für das Handwerk das jetzt
schon mit einer großen
Qualifizierungsoffensive gestartet hat
Sicherheit für die Kommunen bei ihrer
Wärme planen und natürlich Sicherheit
für die vielen vielen Bürgerinnen und
Bürger in diesem Land die sich jetzt für
neue Heizung entscheiden werden und das
ist gut und das ist wichtig
ich sage gleichzeitig auch der Weg zu
diesem Gesetz der war kein leichter wir
als Koalition wir haben auf der Suche
nach der richtigen Lösung hart
miteinander gerungen zu oft auch
öffentlich wir haben es uns gegenseitig
nicht leicht gemacht in diesem
Verhandlungen und wir haben es auch den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern in diesem Land
nicht leicht gemacht während dieser
Verhandlung wir haben Verunsicherung
erzeugt damit die nicht nötig gewesen
wäre das müssen wir in Zukunft besser
machen das werden wir in Zukunft besser
machen
aber am Ende dieses harten Ringens stand
am Ende eine gemeinsame Lösung und damit
übernehmen alle drei Fraktionen der
Ampel eine Verantwortung eine
Verantwortung dafür dass man handeln
muss eine Verantwortung dafür dass man
Entscheidungen in einer Regierung
treffen muss die nötig sind
Entscheidungen treffen muss die richtig
sind und nicht nur Entscheidungen die
einfach sind und dass das möglich war da
bin ich stolz auf alle drei Fraktionen
in dieser Koalition
ich hätte mich gefreut liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen von der Union wenn Sie
diesen Gesetz heute zustimmen würden bei
der Umsetzung des Pariser klimavertrags
bei der größten Herausforderung unserer
Zeit der Bewahrung dieses Planetens und
der Zukunft unserer Kinder da sind wir
am Ende alle gefragt da kann man nicht
einfach zuschauen sie genauso wenig wie
wir und deswegen bitte ich sie einfach
geben Sie sich vielleicht doch noch
einen Ruck stimmen sie am Ende zu es ist
ein gutes Gesetz
und für die Unionsfraktion hat das Wort
der Kollege Alexander Dobrindt
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in der letzten
Sitzungswoche hat das
Bundesverfassungsgericht der Ampel mit
seinem Beschluss einen Auftrag gegeben
dieser Auftrag ist zu Recht in weiten
Teilen als Klatsche verstanden worden
der Auftrag war nämlich dieses Gesetz
nicht einfach zu beschließen sondern zu
beraten und Frau dröge was haben sie
gemacht keine einzige Minute beraten
keine Expertenanhörung gemacht sie haben
unser Wunsch sogar abgelehnt darüber zu
beraten
das ist nicht nur eine Missachtung des
Parlaments und des
Bundesverfassungsgericht das ist vor
allem eine Respektlosigkeit gegenüber in
allen Bürgerinnen und Bürger die einen
Anspruch darauf haben dass sie
ordentlich beraten wird
verehrte Frau dröge sie reden hier von
sozialer Sicherung und von Begeisterung
und gestehen eines hat vielleicht etwas
Unsicherheit gegeben nein es hat keine
Unsicherheit gegeben es gibt Angst in
der Bevölkerung es gibt Proteste in der
Bevölkerung und sie sind verweigern
auf unsere Anfrage hin konnten sie ja
nicht mal sagen was dieser heizhammer an
CO2 Einsparungen bringt jetzt tauchen
gestern Abend auf einmal Schätzungen auf
die sie anscheinend nicht in der Lage
sind richtig zu interpretieren drei
unterschiedliche Szenarien werden jetzt
plötzlich dargestellt im schlechtesten
Fall übrigens gibt es fast keine
CO2-Einsparung deswegen habe ich
Verständnis dass sie sich auf den
mittleren Fall beziehen wollen in ihrer
Prognose aber ich sage Ihnen diese
mittlere Fall ihre Prognose der Schaft
im Durchschnitt 5 Millionen Tonnen CO2
Einsparung zum Vergleich das Abschalten
der drei Kernkraftwerke schafft
zusätzliche 15 Millionen Tonnen das ist
ihre Bilanz bei der CO2 Einsparung
und zu ihrer weiteren Bilanz bei diesem
Gesetz gehört dass die Menschen
schlichtweg Angst haben dass sie sich
das ampelheizsgesetz nicht leisten
können werden und diese Angst sie ist
schlichtweg berechtigt dieses Gesetz
polarisiert in der Gesellschaft die
Menschen haben Angst dass sie das von
der Ampel verordnete gesetzlich nicht
leisten können sie reden hier über
Fördersätze Grundförderung 30 Prozent
Geschwindigkeitsbonus 20 Prozent was sie
nicht sagen ist dass sie einen
förderdeckel eingezogen haben von 15.000
Euro und egal ob die Heizung 50.000
60.000 70.000 € kosten wird man bekommt
nur 15000 €. wo soll denn der Rest
herkommen
und der heben Sie von einer sozialen
Komponente nein dieses Gesetz macht die
Menschen arm das ist die Wahrheit bei
ihrer Förderung und ich sage Ihnen
sehen übrigens nicht nur wir so die
Verbände haben ihnen gestern noch
mitgeteilt dass ihre geplanten
Fördersätze jetzt hinter der bisherigen
Förderung zurückfallt sie fördern
weniger als bisher ihr Gesetz schafft
schlichtweg mehr Zwang und weniger
soziale Gerechtigkeit das ist die
Wahrheit in diesem Gesetz
ja ich wissen Sie ich finde es
eigentlich ein bisschen schäbig dass sie
es anders versuchen darzustellen als es
drin steht sie reden davon sie reden
davon dass sie die Lade die kleinen
Einkommen besonders fördern diese
kleinen Einkommen das sind Menschen die
nach ihrem Gesetz weniger als 40.000
Euro im Jahr brutto verdienen 40.000 €
heißt weniger als 2500 Euro im Monat
netto egal ob einer allein oder eine
Familie und jetzt erklären Sie mal wie
man mit weniger als 2500 € im Monat 30
40 50.000 € für Ihre Heizung ausgeben
soll
und jetzt haben sie hier dazwischen
gerufen und gefragt wo sind denn
eigentlich unsere Änderungsanträge ich
sage Ihnen wir haben einen Antrag heute
gestellt in der Vergangenheit haben sie
sich hier allen Beratungen entzogen wir
haben den Antrag heute gestellt wir
setzen auf Anreize und nicht auf Zwang
es geht um Freiwilligkeit das kann man
mit Abfahrt Prämie und CO2 Bepreisung
machen die meisten Menschen in
Deutschland sie wollen einen Beitrag zum
Klimaschutz leisten aber sie wollen von
Ihnen nicht finanziell überfordert
werden dabei darum geht es doch hier
so
dieses heizgesetz ist der Gipfel der
Respektlosigkeit gegenüber Bürgerinnen
und Bürger und deswegen geht es nicht
darum wie man es verändern kann es geht
darum dass es wieder abgeschafft werden
muss und das ist unser Beitrag dazu
herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
für die SPD-Fraktion hat das Wort dr
Matthias Mörsch
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der fährt der Herr Dobrindt ja
ich habe das befürchtet dass eine solche
Rede kommt und sie zeigt welche
Herausforderungen wir in diesem
Parlament auch in den nächsten Jahren
noch haben werden denn wir haben es in
der großen Koalition nicht hinbekommen
die großen Sektoren Gebäude und Verkehr
klimapolitisch und sozialgerecht
tatsächlich zu gestalten
und ich muss Sie Fragen an dieser Stelle
gilt das Klimaschutzgesetz für Sie
weiterhin wollen wir
2045 klimaneutral sein Ja oder Nein
stehen sie zu diesem Ziel ja oder nein
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und dann frage ich Sie welche Angebote
welche Angebote außer ein allgemeinen
Antrag den Sie hier im Mai nach unseren
Beratungen gestellt haben haben sie
heute um dieses Gesetz zu verbessern
nicht kein einzigen
Herr Hallmann hat nach seinem Erfolg und
das sei ihm zugebilligt in der taz am
19.07 auf die Frage geantwortet die
Frage lautet glauben Sie dass es
Änderungen geben wird da sagt der Zitat
das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen das hängt
jetzt auch von uns ab was wir
vorschlagen werden daran arbeiten einige
in der Union unter anderem ich wo sind
diese Vorschläge liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
ich liebe Herr Kollege Mensch erlauben
sie eine Zwischenfrage von Thomas
Heilmann
vielen Dank dass Sie die Zwischenfrage
zulassen Herr Dr mich sie haben mich ja
gerade selber angesprochen ich habe
diese Dinge erarbeitet ja gerne sie
haben mich gerade angesprochen ich habe
diese Änderungsvorschläge erarbeitet und
habe darauf gewartet es ist eine
Gelegenheit im parlamentarischen
Verfahren gibt dass wir das einbringen
können und meine Idee ist ehrlich gesagt
nicht
dass wir Anträge stellen die sowieso
abgelehnt werden denn das
Entschuldigung jetzt hören sie kurz zu
wenn sie den § 84 unser Geschäftsordnung
kennen dann wissen Sie ganz genau dass
wenn sie heute auch nur einen einzigen
Änderungsantrag annehmen wir heute nicht
die dritte Lesung hätten wir damit in
der nächsten Sitzungswoche wären und sie
den Bundesrat nicht erreichen würden und
warum erwarten sie von der Opposition
dass wir Änderungsanträge stellen von
denen wir schon technisch vorher wissen
dass sie in gar keinen Fall
erlangen werden ich möchte sie noch
etwas weiteres hinweisen dass immer
untergeht
einige aus ihren Fraktionen haben diese
Liste die ich erarbeitet habe die die
ich es gab ja keine Ausschusssitzung
warum eigentlich nicht da hätte man das
ja alles wunderbar debattieren können
ich möchte sie auch noch etwas hinweisen
das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat
ausdrücklich
hat ausdrücklich auf Artikel 42 des
Grundgesetzes referiert und da steht das
Wort verhandeln und verhandeln heißt
aushandeln heißt beraten erörtern
vermitteln wenn sie im Duden nachsehen
das ist nicht die Debatte der zweiten
dritten Lesung sondern das ist in der
Tradition unseres deutschen Bundestages
eine Ausschusssitzung und warum konnten
wir in drei Monaten keine
Ausschusssitzung machen frage ich Sie
warum konnte der Familienausschuss diese
Woche an der Sitzung machen warum konnte
der Verteidigungsausschuss eine Sitzung
machen warum konnte der Innenausschuss
zwei Sitzungen machen aber der
klimaausschuss konnte obwohl wir es am
Dienstag auch noch mal beantragt haben
keine Sitzung machen und jetzt werden
sie uns vor wir hätten nichts dazu
konstruktives sagen können blockieren
sie das doch bitte nicht
lieber Herr Kollege Heimann zunächst
vielen Dank für die Ausführung denn sie
machen doch eins klar ihr Verständnis
von Parlamentarismus scheint ein völlig
anderes zu sein jedenfalls als meins
der Ursprung
der ich kann ich kann hier nur
diskutieren ich kann in Gremien nur
diskutieren und um den besten Weg Ringen
wenn ich Vorschläge von ihnen habe und
ich habe kein einzigen gehört
ich werde zu heute bereit gewesen aber
ich will ihnen das sagen was ich bis
jetzt von ihnen als Änderungsvorschläge
vernommen habe
das erste ist dass sie in einem weiteren
Interview gesagt haben dieses Gesetz
muss Technologie offener sein jetzt
frage ich sie welchen Gesetzentwurf sie
meinen natürlich hätte mir auch ein paar
Stunden weniger Arbeit erwünscht wenn
die Regierung einen anderen Vorschlag
gemacht hätte aber den den wir heute
gehen wir heute abstimmen der sieht ein
eigenen Paragraph zum Thema
technologieoffenheit vor nun weiß ich
nicht
nun weiß ich nicht aber danke dass ich
diese Gelegenheit jetzt bekomme auf
ihrer auf ihre Zwischenfrage weil diesen
Vorschlag hätten sie ja jetzt eben auch
in Ihrer Frage noch mal einbauen können
aber ich sage es Ihnen ich weiß nicht
nach diesem atomwahn den sie ja im
Moment unterlegen ob er sparen
beispielsweise noch an mini-reaktoren
etc arbeitet aber ansonsten haben wir
von Holzpellets bis Geothermie
fernabärme alle Möglichkeiten in diesem
Gesetz liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und dann haben sie
und dann haben sie einen zweiten
Vorschlag gemacht aber auch hier jetzt
heute wieder nicht gesagt aber ich will
mich dem stellen weil dann haben sie
gesagt sie setzen auf den
Emissionshandel und auf die Preisung
und da sage ich ihnen Heimann das können
wir in 3000 Ausschüssen beraten das
können wir hier heute bearbeiten diese
Zustimmung für diesen Pfad werden sie in
der SPD-Fraktion niemals bekommen denn
wozu führt dieser Vorschlag und deswegen
habe ich ihnen die Frage gestellt ob
2045 Klimaneutralität tatsächlich
weitergeht denn wenn sie über die Preise
gehen dann hat das zur Folge dass sie
einen schleichendes ein in Form des
Verbot für viele viele Menschen
einführen denn sie machen dann den Preis
für die fossilen so hoch dass sie sich
schlichtweg Heizen nicht mehr leisten
können aber auch ohne die Möglichkeit zu
haben umzusteigen und das ist unsozial
sie haben kein Recht
ich nehme an Sie haben die Frage jetzt
beantwortet sondern weil man dann
wirklich jeder weiterlaufen einmal
gehört habe ich warte aber auf andere
wenn sie denn heute im Laufe des
Verfahrens doch vorgebracht werden nur
das ist der große Unterschied wenn sie
so Klimaschutz machen in diesem
Bereichen werden sie weite Teile der
Bevölkerung nicht mitnehmen können das
ist nicht unser Weg
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
deswegen ich glaube dass an diesem
Gesetz deutlich wird dass ich
Parlamentarismus lohnt wir haben an
vielen vielen Stellen dieses Gesetz
völlig nachgebessert wir haben es mit
einer Struktur versehen das als erstes
im Jahr 2026 und 2028 die Kommunen mit
einer kommunalen wärmeplanung den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern eine Struktur
und Sicherheit geben das ist unser
Ausgangspunkt und der ist richtig und
wichtig
ein weiterer wichtiger Punkt ist dass
wir nicht auf die Technologie setzen die
eine Technologie weil in Regionen
Deutschland unterschiedlich aufgestellt
ist und es auch ein großer Unterschied
ist ob ich in einem Ballungszentrum oder
auf dem Land wohne dieses Gesetz
ermöglicht die Bandbreite neuer
Technologien auch das ist ein
wesentlicher Fortschritt im Vergleich
zum Regierungsentwurf liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
und dann haben wir am Ende auch ein
Förderprogramm aufgesetzt so dass und
nur über diese Fälle reden wir dann wenn
die Heizungsanlage kaputt ist habe ich
ohnehin ein Invest was in der Regel im
vierstelligen bis fünfstelligen Bereich
auch heute schon liegt unser Ziel ist es
eine Förderkulisse aufzusetzen die
ermöglicht dass ich in diesem Rahmen wie
bisher auch eine neue Heizungsanlage die
aber dann zukunftstauglich ist mir
leisten können dass wir niemanden im
Stich lassen und das haben wir hier
vorgelegt
und zum Abschluss der Heilmann ich hoffe
dass ich Ihnen die Unterschiede zwischen
Ihnen und uns erklärt habe aber jetzt
gibt es ja noch jemanden der sich auch
zu Wort gemeldet hat nämlich der Chef
der Jungen Union der erklärt vorgestern
dass er überhaupt dieses
heizungsgesetzlich will weil es zu viele
Steuergelder kosten würde er will also
keine Förderung meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren sie haben das Recht
dass wir hier in Parlament beraten sie
haben aber nicht das Recht dass wir
Ihren Vorschlägen zustimmen ich danke
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
und für die afd-fraktion hat das Wort
Mark Bernhard
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
sie von der Ampel wollen uns jetzt hier
also allen Ernstes erzählen dass alles
paletti ist das ist eben nicht ja
heizungshammer ist nicht verschoben und
er ist auch nicht entschärft hören Sie
auf die Bürger anzulügen
denn was hat sich denn tatsächlich
geändert rein gar nichts nix denn was
muss ich denn machen wenn ich nächstes
Jahr meine Heizung tauschen muss ja
richtig solange meine Gemeinde noch
keine wärmeplanung abgeschlossen hat
kann ich zwar vormalen einbauen was ich
will aber wenn dann zwei oder vier Jahre
später die wärmeplanung vorliegt und
meine Heizung nicht dazu passt da muss
ich sie wieder rausreißen oder eine
zweite daneben stellen wenn Sie sich zum
Beispiel für eine Gasheizung entschieden
haben können Sie diese nur weiter
betreiben wenn ihre Stadtwerke zukünftig
mindestens 65 Prozent Biogas durch die
Rohre schicken das ist völlig absurd
denn von welchen Feldern und Kühen
sollen das ganze Biogas für 85 Millionen
Menschen in herkommen
das ist genauso aber witzig und
weltfremd wie das Heizen mit dem
wasserstoffmärchen aus Afrika damit
bleibt es nach wie vor bei der
Wärmepumpe als einzige mögliche Lösung
alles andere sind nichts als Nebelkerzen
ihr Gesetz ist ein Handbuch zu
Vernichtung unseres Wohlstands
denn der Einbau in der Wärmepumpe und
die notwendige energetische Sanierung
für ein Einfamilienhaus kostet
mindestens 100.000 Euro ihr und ihr
heizungshammer trifft jeden egal ob
Eigentümer oder Mieter denn damit wird
die Miete im Durchschnitt um mehr als
200 Euro steigen und ihre angebliche
Kappungsgrenze von 20 Cent pro
Quadratmeter ändert daran überhaupt gar
nichts denn bevor ein Vermieter Verlust
macht wird er entweder gar nicht mehr
vermieten oder er muss seinen Weg finden
die Kosten auf die Miete umzulegen nur
diese Möglichkeiten gibt es ihr
heizungshammer kostet die Menschen nach
Berechnungen der FDP Herr Köhler ihres
eigenen Koalitionspartners habe
2500 Milliarden Euro also 30.000 Euro
pro Kopf der Bevölkerung das ist ihre
Berechnung für und für diese waren
sinnige Summe wollen Sie denn schreiben
Sie doch nicht so für diese wahnsinnige
Summe wollen unintelligible den
CO2-Ausstoß in Deutschland gerade mal um
ein einziges lächerliches Prozent
reduzieren und nicht mal dabei Herr
haramweg sind sie sich sicher zum
Vergleich was sie mit dieser sozialen
Katastrophe ihres heizungshammers in
sechs Jahren ein CO2 einsparen wollen
blästina in gerade mal 32 Stunden in die
Luft hätten sie doch stattdessen einfach
die drei Kernkraftwerke im April
weiterlaufen lassen würden wir doppelt
so viel CO2 einsparen wie mit ihrem
gesamten heizungssammler ohne dass uns
jetzt irgendwas kosten würde daran sieht
man die Ehre ihre Politik ist sie
zwingen uns Bürger gegen jede Logik und
Vernunft etwas auf das uns verarmt und
enteignet ohne irgendeinen Nutzen weder
fürs Klima noch für die Menschen ihr
heizungshammer ist nichts anderes als
ein aubzug gegen das eigene Volk und wer
ihren Namen Wahnsinn nicht mitmacht den
bedrohen sie mit bis zu 50.000 € Bußgeld
wir lehnen diesen heizungshammer nach
wie vor streckt ab eine afd-regierung
wird diesen Raubzug sofort beenden und
dieses Gesetz wieder rückgängig machen
das Wort hat der Kollege Christian dürr
für die FDP-Fraktion
frau Präsidentin liebe Kollegen Kollegen
ich habe mich zu Wort gemeldet weil ich
den Eindruck hatte nach der Kollege des
nach der Rede des Kollegen Alexander
Dobrindt dass die Gedanken noch nicht
ganz zu Ende geführt sind auch nicht bei
der Union ich könnte den economis
zitieren der die technologieoffenheit
des deutschen Gebäuden Energiegesetzes
wird ich könnte den Präsidenten von Haus
und Grund zitieren der sagt welche faire
und richtige Ausgleich zwischen Mietern
und Vermietern hier getroffen worden ist
aber ich glaube in dieser Stunde müssen
wir in der Auseinandersetzung zwischen
Regierungsfraktion und Opposition auch
über den Parlamentarismus hier reden sie
liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen der Union
Herr Dobrind hatten acht Wochen Zeit
Änderungsanträge zu erarbeiten und der
Heilmann hat das sehr wichtig
hat das sehr richtig gerade in seiner
Antwort gesagt Kollege mir schaut ihn
jetzt zitiert er hat gesagt es könnte
sein dass wenn wir Änderungsanträge
stellen im Plenum dass die
Regierungsfraktionen nicht zustimmen ja
das kann passieren in den letzten vier
Jahren in der Opposition der
FDP-Fraktion hat diese Bundesregierung
aus cdu/cs und SPD auch nicht einen
Änderungsanträgen der FDP-Fraktion
zugestimmt aber als
Opposition muss man trotzdem arbeiten
man kann sich doch nicht zurücklegen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ist doch
kein Konzept was ist das für eine
Opposition geworden Herr dobrin
die Empfehlung der cdu/csu lautet keine
Änderung des Gebäude Energiegesetzes in
Deutschland die Empfehlung der CDU CDU
lautet die Menschen mit einem alten
überholten Gesetz von vor vielen Jahren
alleine zu lassen die Empfehlung der
Union heißt beispielsweise sich gegen
Technologie oftmals zu entscheiden ich
will und ich weiß dass es umstritten ist
ich will nur ein Beispiel nennen Kollege
dürfen
Sie eine Frage des Kollegen Heilmann ich
habe gute Erfahrungen damit gemacht
gerne
das mit der guten Erfahrung würde ich
teilen vielen Dank dass Sie die Zusage
Zwischenfrage zulassen
ja ich weiß auch nicht was
ich wollte doch
ich wollte ich wollte sie darauf
ansprechen und fragen ob sie die
insgesamt 90 inhaltlichen Fragen die wir
zu diesem heizungsgesetz der
Bundesregierung gestellt haben ob sie
überhaupt gelesen und zu Kenntnis
genommen haben ob ihn aufgefallen ist
dass die Bundesregierung nicht nur in
vielen Stellen ausweichen geantwortet
hat sondern in einem Maße nicht
geantwortet hat dass die
Bundestagspräsidentin ihre Bedenken
geäußert hat aber noch mehr sie haben
ausdrücklich gesagt sie sagen zu der
neuen Vorlage nichts daran hätten sie ja
schon erkennen können dass wir Ärger
gearbeitet haben was wir uns ja gerade
vorgearbeitet haben und zwar sehr im
Detail und Punkt thematisieren wollen
und so rum ist der Parlamentarismus
nicht nicht die Mehrheit entscheidet ob
die Vorschläge der Opposition gut genug
und ausreichend sind dass es Sitzungen
gibt sondern das Parlamentarismus sieht
vor dass es solche Sitzungen gibt und
wir uns dann in diesen Sitzungen
übrigens im Austausch mit Ihnen im
Detail auch Meinungen bilden können das
ist nicht so dass das Grundgesetz sagt
erst wenn die Opposition irgendwelche
Formalia macht dann müssen sie das auch
machen nehmen Sie zur Kenntnis dass über
diesen Gesetzentwurf und der Fassung
über die wir heute abschließend beraten
der Ausschuss insgesamt nur 30 Minuten
getagt hat und danach nie wieder und die
können die Kollege mir statt diese Frage
nicht beantwortet warum sie das
Verfahren so gewählt haben und warum es
nicht möglich war dass wir mehr darüber
beraten können
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Heilmann es
gibt mir die Gelegenheit auf der
Öffentlichkeit nochmal deutlich zu
machen dass der Fachausschuss in zwei
anhören sich damit beschäftigt hat aber
davon abgesehen sie sind ja der einzige
in der cdu/csu-fraktion der sich
inhaltlich mit dem Gebäude Energiegesetz
beschäftigt hat das Anerkennung das ist
aber ich habe die Fragen gelesen und ich
habe mich eines selbst gefragt welches
marktwirtschaftliche wirtschaftliche
Verständnis hat eigentlich die Union die
Herangehensweise der Fragen ist ja wie
folgt Herr Bundesminister sagen sie uns
ganz genau und welchem Jahr in welchem
Sektor Teilsektor der gebäudeenergie wie
viel CO2 wie eingespart wird das
erreicht man über einen einzigen Weg
indem man sich für Planwirtschaft
entscheidet diese Koalition hat sich
aber für technologieoffenheit
entschieden und die Ziele des
gebäudesektors die sind ganz klar die
sind nämlich gedeckelt und die werden
wir nur durch technologieoffenheit
erreichen und nicht in dem Glas ob Frau
Müller in der arschstraße so und so viel
CO2 einspart in Zukunft und Herr Meier
in der bestraße eine andere Menge die
Herangehensweise ändert sich fundamental
wir ändert das Klimaschutzgesetz denn
eins ist doch klar dieses Land hat doch
mit planwirtschaftlichen Ansätzen in den
letzten 15 Jahren seine Erfahrung
gemacht an keine einzigen Stelle haben
wir sinnvoll die Klimaschutzziel e
erreicht diese Koalition wer die
Klimaschutz erreichen und das mit
Marktwirtschaft in Verbrennung bringt
das ist der Unterschied zwischen Ihnen
und uns liebe Kollegen Kollegen
und das gibt mir das gibt mir Heimann
die Gelegenheit die Empfehlung die sie
dem Deutschen Bundestag heute machen
noch einmal auszuführen diese Empfehlung
noch einmal auszuführen die Empfehlung
lautet ja das Gebäude Energiegesetz der
großen Koalition nicht zu ändern beim
alten Stand zu lassen in der dobit hat
das deutlich gesagt ich glaube sie haben
eine etwas andere Position in persona
aber Herr Dobrind hat für die Union
Unionsfraktion gesprochen ich will nur
sagen was das bedeutet Kollege Mersch
hat das bereits angedeutet das heißt
dass wir die Menschen einfach und
technologisch und untechnologie offen in
den alten Technologien festzementieren
und das ist schlicht unsinnig wir dürfen
die Menschen mit steigenden CO2 Kosten
nicht alleine lassen nur ein einziges
Beispiel das wollte ich vorhin ausführen
nur ein einziges Beispiel in Bayern
heizen über 30% der Menschen heute mit
Ölheizung ihre Mehrheit hat seinerzeit
beschlossen diese Heizungsform komplett
zu verbieten ich weiß nicht jeden 15
Jahren die einzelnen Technologien in
Deutschland aussehen aber ich weiß eines
die der Deutsche Bundestag sollte sich
nicht die Kompetenz anmaßen ganz genau
zu wissen in welchen Keller welche
Heizung wird das wissen die Menschen
besser und das ist der Unterschied
zwischen Ihnen und uns das ist der
Unterschied
das ist der Unterschied und wenn man und
wenn man und wenn man das zusammenfasst
ich meine das gleiche die gleiche debat
jetzt ringsinnig so auf die gleiche
Debatte haben wir doch haben wir doch
geführt als Markus Söder seinerzeit das
Verbrenner ausgefordert hat und so
weiter und so fort wir haben das von
ihnen alles gehört hier sind sie nicht
in der Lage Änderungsanträge zu stellen
ihre Regierungszeit spricht Bände an der
Stelle was in der Vergangenheit
angestellt haben Klimaschutzziele
gerissen und technologieoffen waren sie
an der Stelle auch nicht diese Koalition
diese Koalition geht nach den
Änderungsanträgen aus den
Regierungsfraktionen einen anderen Weg
bei der Gebäude Energieversorgung in
Deutschland wir wollen Klimaschutz
erreichen wir wollen es
marktwirtschaftlich machen wir wollen es
Technologie aufmachen kurz um die
Heizung muss zum Haus passen und nicht
umgekehrt und so sollte sich der
Deutsche Bundestag entscheiden ich danke
Ihnen
das Wort hat der Kollege Dr Dietmar
Bartsch für die Fraktion
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
was die Ampelkoalition beim
gebäudeenergiegesetz geleistet hat das
ist ein kommunikatives Desaster ist ein
klimapolitisches Desaster und es ist
auch ein Desaster für den
Parlamentarismus ich bin seit einigen
Jahren hier in deutschen Bundestag aber
ein solches Verfahren habe ich seit 98
wirklich noch nicht einmal erlebt meine
Damen und Herren sie haben inzwischen
sie haben inzwischen von den Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern die rote Karte gekriegt alle
umfragen sagen deutlich das wird
abgelegt sie haben vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht vor der
Sommerpause die rote Karte bekommen dann
wollten sie eigentlich sein sie doch
ehrlich eine Sondersitzung machen und
das Ergebnis war Sondersitzung kriegen
wir nicht hin also beschließen wir etwas
und sagen an es gibt keine Veränderung
selbst Komma vieler wollen sie nicht
verändern wo leben wir denn das ist eine
Missachtung meine Damen und Herren eine
Missachtung wo ist eigentlich ihr
Selbstbewusstsein Parlamentarier von SPD
grün und FDP sie lassen das einfach so
sie zer stören Akzeptanz und Vertrauen
bei Menschen und es ist kein Dienst kein
Dienst beim beibringen notwendigen
Maßnahmen gegen die Klimawandel warum
haben Sie eigentlich die Sommerpause
nicht genutzt wir sind doch nicht
Schülerinnen und Schüler denen sie was
vorlegen gucken sich das mal an und dann
beschließen wir das so nein das ist das
ist Arroganz gegenüber den Parlament und
Arroganz gegenüber den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern meine Damen und Herren
meine Fraktion meine Fraktion wird
ihrem Gesetz entsprechend die rote Karte
zeigen ich will nur wenige Argumente
nennen wir haben als der erste
entwurfvorlage habe ich ja nach dem
klimapolitischen Effekt gefragt und die
Antwort lautete da 1,4 Prozent weniger
CO2-Emissionen bis 2030 im Vergleich zu
heute sehr ehrlich gesagt deprimiert
wenig und dann fragt die Union und da
haben sie erstmal gar keine Antwort
gegeben kann ich nur sagen das ist ja
ziemlich interessant jetzt gibt es eine
Antwort aber ehrlich gesagt ist diese
Antwort genauso wie bei der
Kindergrundsicherung und der Bekämpfung
von Kinderarmut wir wissen dass alles
nicht genau was passiert das kann doch
nicht wahr sein meine Damen und Herren
das ist inakzeptabel und das hat
überhaupt nicht geplant Wirtschaft zu
tun ich habe jetzt in der letzten Woche
bewusst noch mal weil er gesagt und wäre
das alles so toll findet mit ein paar
Chef von Stadtwerken gesprochen und die
sagen es ist völlig unverständlich dass
ihr Gesetz nicht mit der kommunalen
wärmeplanung sind konisiert ist das
liegt nicht
seine entscheidendes
koordinierungsinstrumente das nicht da
die lokalen Gegebenheiten sie haben
darauf hingewiesen lieber Herr Milch wo
denn wo liegt denn ein Gesetzentwurf vor
nein nein nein nein das ist eben genau
nicht der Fall das passiert nicht und
noch ein Punkt sie lassen die
Mieterinnen und Mieter im Stich sie
bauen nicht nur keine Wohnung sondern
sie verteuern am Ende auch noch die
Mieten das ist doch die Wahrheit sie
müssen die Modernisierungsumlage
umschauen abschaffen und sie müssen den
Mieterinnen und Mieter ein Versprechen
geben kein Euro mehr Warmmiete für
dieses Gesetz aber das wollen sie nicht
und warum fördern sie nicht eigentlich
die Genossenschaften mehr das wäre
dringend notwendig ich will im übrigen
ausdrücklich sagen schauen Sie sich
unsere Antrag an der ist im übrigen sehr
lesenswert meine Damen und Herren es
gibt was sie den Mietern zumuten da sage
ich klar auch das ist
unfallverantwortlich die Förderung und
da noch Einsatz zu sagen die ist für
normal Bürger ehrlich gesagt auch ein
schlechter Witz sozialgerecht der
Klimaschutz ehrlich gesagt ein Ehepaar
mit 40.000 Euro Jahr Einkommen ich komme
aus Mecklenburg-Vorpommern da gibt's
sowas Bayern vielleicht anders bei uns
bekommt genau so eine Förderung wieder
Multimillionär das kann doch nicht
gerecht sein meine Damen und Herren das
ist unanständig dass die Wahrheit dass
die Wahrheit das ist die Wahrheit meine
Damen und Herren wir hatten ja an dieser
Woche Haushaltsberatung und Christian
Linder hat hier vom Eisberg am Horizont
gesprochen und da ist er vielleicht was
dran aber was sie mit ihrer Politik
machen das ist voll drauf halten auf den
Eisberg und zwar zulassen der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger beim
heizungsgesetz bei steigenden
co2-preisen bei vorgezogener Erhöhung
der Mehrwertsteuer auf Gas und so weiter
und so fort stoppen Sie diesen Irrweg
der weitgehend sinnlosen herzlichen Dank
das Wort hat der Bundesminister für
Botschaft und Klimaschutz dr Robert
Habeck
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren lassen sie mich zum Abschluss
einer ja nun wirklich langen Debatte
also Ramone geht es ja mit
Sachaufklärung mit Sachaufklärung
beginnen
lieber Dobrindt die forderten ja
Wahrhaftigkeit einen bitte nehmen Sie
zur Kenntnis dass da förderdeckel und
der festgesetzt wird nicht 15.000 Euro
sondern 30.000 Euro beträgt nur für den
heizungskaut und der kann kombiniert
werden mit weiteren Maßnahmen und dann
kann man bis zu 90
000 €
nehmen Sie bitte zur Kenntnis dass die
wissenschaftlichen Analysen die den
CO2-Preis wirkungsgleich mit dem GG
berechnen sagen dass sie 2030 ein
CO2-Preis von 200 bis 300 Euro pro Tonne
haben müssen und diese Wirkung zu
erzielen das sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren ich hoffe das verlässt mal den
Plenarsaal das sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren ist der buchstabierte Vorschlag
der Unionsfraktion eine Verzehnfachung
des co2-preises in den nächsten 7 Jahren
das ist die sozialpolitische Maßnahme
der Union und bei allen Vorwürfen wie
sie gegen die Ampel und gegen das
Gebäude Energiegesetz richtet das darf
man auch im wahlkampfeinheit verstehen
was die Union vorschlägt eine Verzehrung
des Preises ohne soziale Kompensation um
dieses Gegner zu ersetzen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren das wird in sozialen
Frieden in Deutschland zerlegen deswegen
bin ich ganz bei Matthi as Mörsch das
sollten wir nicht tun und sie sollten
noch mal in sich kehren und nicht nur
behaupten sondern auch Fakten Erkenntnis
nehmen Herr Bundesminister gestatten Sie
eine Frage oder Bemerkung der
Abgeordneten vom Storch eine nein
selbstverständlich nicht jemand der den
Klimawandel leugnet in der Debatte
schweigen
weiterhin bitte nehmen Sie zur Kenntnis
jetzt diesen Fall die Linke dass der
Bonus der soziale Bonus gekoppelt ist an
einer Einkommensgrenze bis zu 40.000
Euro Jahreseinkommen das heißt es kriegt
eben nicht der Millionär der gleich das
gleiche wie gering oder
mittelverdienende Einkommen weiterhin
weiterhin
lassen Sie mich langsam vielleicht zum
Kern zum eigentlichen Kern der Debatte
kommen ja es ist richtig dass die die
Institute die wir beauftragt haben den
co2-effekt auszurechnen komplizierte
Berechnung Annahmen nehmen mussten wie
sollte es auch anders sein sie müssen
mir erstmal rausfinden und schätzen wie
viel
wärmepläne in den Kommunen gemacht
werden dann vermutlich eine
Preisentwicklung bei den Wärmepumpen
annehmen einen Hochlauf von CO2
Zertifikaten oder eine Produktion
meinetwegen kann Wasserstoff das sind
natürlich alles Prognosen wie geht man
bei Prognosen vor man bildet den
mittleren Wert was ist der Sinn von
einem mittleren Wert es gibt einen über
den unteren das geht bisher kein
mittleren Wert das tun wir aber immer
und überall von der Steuerschätzung bis
zur Pkw-Entwicklung immer nehmen wir den
mittleren Wert und der mittlere Wert
sagt dass wir mit diesem veränderten
Gesetz drei Viertel der Emission des
alten Gesetzentwurfs ein spannend
dreiviertel das ist richtig viel das ist
richtig gut denn der alte Info wurde ja
für gescheiten ist der zu ehrgeizig ist
in Summe sind es 40 Millionen Tonnen
kumuliert bis 2030 nehmen Sie den oberen
wert sind 50 Millionen Tonnen so und
damit zum eigentlichen Kern und zum
eigentlichen Problem Sie können
natürlich sagen 40 Millionen Tonnen oder
50 Millionen Tonnen das sind ja nicht
500 Millionen Tonnen oder 5000 Millionen
Tonnen sehr geehrte Damen und Herren das
ist genau das Problem der Klima Debatte
die wir die letzten Jahre hatten und die
wir geerbt haben als Ampelkoalition weil
sie nichts tun werden die Summen immer
größer weil sie noch nicht mal bereit
sind die konkreten ersten Schritte zu
gehen stehen wir vor einem Berg von
Problemen und weil wir mit lauter
Einzelmaßnahmen vorangegangen sind haben
wir die von Ihnen gelernt geerbte
klimaschutzlücke von
1.100 Millionen Tonnen kumuliert bis
2030 auf 200 Millionen Tonnen verringert
jetzt setzen Sie es bitte ins Verhältnis
ich habe ja auch heute schon gehört oder
in der Debatte die Klimaschutz
Anstrengungen der
Ampel sind nicht groß genug jetzt werfen
Sie uns vor dass dieser Schritt nicht
ausreichend ist aber sie selbst sie sind
ja gar nicht in der Lage irgendeinen
Schritt vorzuschlagen außer die Leute
mit
300 € bekommen
und das sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
das ist das das ist der Grund für das
Gebäude Energiegesetz dass wir und
vielleicht geht die politische Amnesie
nicht so weit dass sie schon vergessen
haben auch die Union vor einigen Jahren
beschlossen hat dass Deutschland 2045
klimaneutral sein soll
abstrakt gut konkret nicht konkret
miserabel konkret keine Maßnahmen
vorgeschlagen ich habe es ja eben schon
ausgekliniert und das Problem des
Gesetzes und das weiß ich und alle
sollten es wissen das Problem des
Gesetzes der Debatte ist dass wenn
abstrakte Vorschläge konkret werden ist
natürlich bedeutet dass Menschen direkt
betroffen sind und es ist natürlich
etwas ganz anderes den Kohleausstieg bei
den Atomausstieg zu beschließen oder ein
Gebäude Energiegesetz wo wirklich
Millionen von Haushalten konkret
betroffen sind dass das eine andere
Debatte ist eine schwieriger eine
Debatte die Sorgen die Sorgen verursacht
die konkrete Fragen stellt die eine
Vielfalt von Fragen stellt das ist in
der Tat so und ich weiß dass diese
Debatte ja in Deutschland eine Menge von
Nachfragen bis hin zu Verunsicherung
nach sich gezogen hat die jetzt mit dem
Gesetz so meine ich gut beantwortet sind
man soll die Menschen
man soll die Menschen die sich Sorgen
machen
sehr sehr ernst nehmen von meiner Seite
gibt es
überhaupt nichts Negatives an dieser
Form der Debatte ich finde es berechtigt
mit konkreten und auch besorgten
Nachfragen auf dieses Gesetz einzugehen
was man allerdings nicht durchgehen
lassen sollte ist den Menschen Sand ins
Auge zu streuen zu sagen wir machen
Ziele aber wir tun nichts dafür dass
diese Ziele erreicht werden dieses
Gesetz schafft Rechtssicherheit ist
schützt die Verbraucher und die
Verbraucher von den hohen Energiepreisen
ist sorgt dafür dass die Kommunen und
die Verbände mitgenommen werden es sorgt
für eine soziale Ausbalancierung des
Gesetzes ist es ein gutes Gesetz dass
wir heute verabschieden werden danke
schön
für die cdu/csu-fraktion hat nun der
Kollege Jens Spahn
h frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Herr Minister Habeck hat
gestern hier im Plenum erklärt ich
zitiere raus aus der Komfortzone der
Selbstzufriedenheit das muss das Motto
unserer Zeit sein was haben wir hier
gerade gesehen sie haben sich noch
tiefer eingebuddelt in ihrer selbst
Zufriedenheit Selbstkritik war hier
nicht zu spüren nach den letzten Monaten
sparen Sie sich solche Zitate hier in
ihren Reden wenn sie dann anschließend
hier so handeln
80 Prozent der Deutschen vertrauen ihnen
vertrauen dieser Regierung nicht mehr
75 Prozent sorgen sich dass sie der
Austausch ihrer Heizungen finanziell
überfordern könnte und da sie ja Herr
Minister Habeck anscheinend ihr eigenes
heute verteiltes Papier zu den
Förderprogrammen nicht kennen will ich
jetzt noch mal sagen die förderfähigen
Kosten sind 30.000 maximal förderfähigen
die meisten werden nur ein Fördersatz
von 30 bis 50 Prozent bekommen einige
wenige etwas mehr das heißt die
allermeisten bekommen maximal 15.000 bei
Kosten von 30 40 50.000 Euro ich weiß
nicht Frau dröge sie haben gerade gesagt
die Menschen sind froh ich weiß nicht in
welchem Land Sie unterwegs sind ich
erlebe gestandene Rentnerinnen und
Rentner die mit Tränen in den Augen zu
einem kommen weil sie nicht wissen wie
sie das bezahlen sollen in welcher Welt
leben Sie denn eigentlich
und was was ist ihre Antwort auf diese
Verunsicherung in der Bevölkerung gegen
die überwältigende Mehrheitsmeinung in
der Bevölkerung und in der Fachwelt
Peitschen sie ohne Rücksicht auf
Verluste hier heute ihr Gesetz durch sie
ignorieren die Ansage des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts sie befördern
Wut Frust Verdruss im Land ihr
heizungsgesetz ist ein
vertrauensverlustgesetz das ist das was
sie anrichten sie sind ein
Konjunkturprogramm für die Populisten im
Land das ist das eigentliche Problem
der Kanzler meinte vorgestern ist läge
Mehltau über dem Land ist ersticke an
Bürokratie schauen Sie sich mal ihr
heizungsgesetz an es ist kleinteilig es
versucht alles zu regeln schafft damit
doch nur mehr Unsicherheit sie wollen
die Lufthoheit über den Heizungskellern
aus allen Poren des Gesetzes quilters
große Misstrauen gegen die Bürger gegen
die Handwerker gegen die ganze Welt der
Mehltau in diesem Land das sind sie mit
ihren bürokratischen Gesetzen und dieses
hier ist ein ganz besonders schlechtes
Beispiel dafür und da helfen übrigens
auch drei Änderungsanträge nichts um das
wieder zu verändern und von lieber Herr
Tür lieber Herr dürr da können Sie hier
noch so sehr unter dem Applaus der Ampel
die Opposition beschimpfen ihre Ampel
FDP im Bund leistet heute einen großen
Beitrag dazu dass die bayerische FDP
nicht in den Landtag kommen wird wieder
Vorlage 8 Oktober da bin ich sehr sehr
sicher
ja wir werden sehen wir werden sehen
sie können der Minister bis heute nicht
nachvollziehbar darlegen wie viel CO2
durch dieses Gesetz eigentlich
eingespart wird sie haben gerade noch
mal wieder Zahlen genannt ich will das
aber mal einordnen
ich will das mal einordnen sie geben
viele zig Milliarden Euro bis 2030 30
als Förderung aus sie verunsichern
Millionen Menschen die zwingen Millionen
Hausbesitzer zum Umbau sie sparen damit
so viel CO2 in 7 Jahren wie das
Weiterlaufen der drei Kernkraftwerke in
einem Jahr gespart hätte es geht darum
wie wir effizient CO2 sparen und nicht
möglichst teuer das ist der Unterschied
in der Politik zwischen ihnen und und
sie schmeißen immer nur Geld
ausprobieren wir wollen Effizienz
auflösen
und deswegen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen frau Präsidentin ist für uns
als Union klar wenn wir 2025 wieder
regieren werden wir das bewährte heutige
System von CO2 Bepreisung fairer
Förderung und technologieoffenheit
wieder etablieren wir werden dieses
heizungsgesetz wieder zurücknehmen sie
Verfahren gerade nach dem Motto als sie
das Ziel aus den Augen verloren
verdoppelten sie die Geschwindigkeit
stoppen Sie diesen wir sind kommen sie
zu Besinnung liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
der guten Ordnung halber weiß ich darauf
hin dass wie immer ich mir natürlich das
vorabprotokoll dieser Debatte ansehen
werde und mir auch Ordnungsmaßnahmen
oder Rügen zu Zwischenrufen und
ähnlichen Vorbehalte wir fahren in der
Debatte fort das Wort hat die Kollegin
Verena Huberts für die spd-fra
ktion sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen es ist schon
verwunderlich was die Union ja heute
präsentiert stoppen ohne Vorschläge und
ich frag mich warum man eigentlich
Rechte einfordert der Mitbestimmung und
dann am Ende des Tages überhaupt nichts
wahrnimmt und hier überhaupt gar keinen
einzigen Vorschlag präsentiert das ist
Verzögerung das ist Blockierung das ist
Union in der Vergangenheit nicht in der
Zukunft
und vielleicht kann man sich ja auch
noch mal dran erinnern der
Klimaschutzgesetz und Klimaschutzziele
hier gemeinsam beschlossen hat und jetzt
zu blockieren und zu sagen wir nehmen
das sogar noch mal zurück das ist
Misstrauen das ist kein Vertrauen in
Zukunft und das ist das was sie hier
heute gemacht haben
und am Ende des Tages haben wir jetzt ja
auch noch mal gehört das Rechnen nicht
jedem gegeben ist denn wir haben doch
auf eins Wert gelegt dass wir
Klimaschutz mit dem Gesetz hinbekommen
dass es sozialverträglich ist und
praxistauglich aber das überfordert
einige hier anscheinend in diesem Raum
und Herr Bartsch sie haben gefragt warum
das denn jetzt mit der kommunalen
wärmeplanung nicht synchronisiert ist
ich empfehle Ihnen noch mal sehr genau
sich mit den Texten auseinanderzusetzen
die kommunale wärmeplanung ist um
Zentrum dieses Gesetzes und beides wird
am
1.1.2024 in Kraft treten Kolleginnen
Kommunikation
gerade ein bisschen reinschauen in ihrer
Fraktion Kollegin Hubert gestanden sie
eine Frage oder Bemerkung des Kollegen
linke nein das wird gestatte ich nicht
es geht jetzt erstmal hier drum dass wir
das Gesetz mit der kommunalen
wärmeplanung verzahnen dicke Städte
haben jetzt Zeit bis 26 bis 28 zu
schauen was haben wir denn vor bei uns
konkret vor Ort Nahwärme zu nutzen
Biogas zu nutzen zu schauen wie
vielleicht auch Wasserstoff entstehen
kann denn wir haben es doch wirklich
jetzt technologieoffen gemacht Öl
Pellets und eben auch die Holz gerade im
ländlichen Raum wo das Holz eben auch so
wichtig ist ist das eine ganz
wesentliche Sache dass wir hier nichts
vorgeben sondern dieses Gesetz wirklich
auch praxistauglich ist und weil sie
auch gesagt haben die Mieterinnen und
Mieter werden nicht ausreichend
geschützt da sagen wir Ihnen mal und der
Kollege Kevin Kühnert wird da gleich
sicherlich noch mal zum Schluss der
Debatte drauf eingehen wir haben die
Modernisierungsumlage auf 50 Cent
beschränkt damit eben niemand aus der
Wohnung raus saniert wird das ist doch
die Wahrheit
wir sehen aber nicht nur die eine Seite
sondern auch die andere Seite und wir
haben eine Förderkulisse geschaffen die
auch für die Wohnungswirtschaft gilt
damit wir eben gemeinsam dahin kommen
dass das richtige eingebaut wird und mit
einem Speed Bonus versehen auch noch ein
bisschen schneller als uns das
vielleicht der ein oder andere zugetraut
hätte in einem neuen Tempo für dieses
Land damit wir eben auch diese
wärmewende gemeinsam hinbekommen
und es geht auch um Diversität der
Lösung diversität ist ja auch nicht
unbedingt Vorteil oder das was die Union
auszeichnet sondern wir haben ja nicht
einen Weg wie wir dahin kommen sondern
es wird eine ganz verschiedene Art und
Weise der Lösung geben ich komme zum
Beispiel aus Trier wir haben dort sehr
vorbildliche Stadtwerke die machen aus
der Kläranlage die waren mal in
Energieversorger da wird bald ein
Energie
wasserstoffnetz entstehen von dem
Verbrauch von Energie zum Versorgen von
Energie das können sie sich vielleicht
nicht vorstellen auch nicht alles wird
über eine Erdwärmepumpe lösbar sein z.B
kann man in Trier nicht buddeln weil da
gibt's immer über einen römischen Schatz
da werden wir überquartiers Ansätze auch
vorangehen und gucken wie kriegen wir
auch über die Stadtteile hinweg alles
klimaneutral das heißt nicht eine Lösung
für alle sondern das Land ist
unterschiedlich in meinem Wahlkreis kann
man das konkret sehen vielleicht schauen
sie mal mit uns in die Zukunft und
bleiben nicht in der Vergangenheit
stehen und beschließen heute dieses
Gesetz mit anstatt ist nur zu blockieren
herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
zur Pension erteillich dem Kollegen Ralf
lenke das Wort
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Frau
Kollegin Huberts es gibt ein
Kabinettsbeschluss zu kommunalen
wärmeplanung ja der Kabinettsbeschluss
zum GEG war dann am Ende doch anders wie
wir heute beschließen das heißt wir
wissen nicht was kommt und wenn ich die
Inhalte bisher sehe sie wollen eine
kommunale wärmeplanung Gesetz
verabschieden ab 24 die soll 28
abgeschlossen sein und gleichzeitig
schließen Sie den den Träger der
Informationen de facto aus weil sie
nämlich die wärmeplanung nicht an
Stadtwerke geben wollen nicht an die
regionalen grundversorge sondern ein
externe Projektierungsbüros ich frage
Sie also woher sollen die vielen
tausenden Fachleute kommen die das
schaffen sollen gleichzeitig die
wärmewendeplan gleichzeitig alles
umsetzen diese Planung ist Muts und wenn
sie mal ein bisschen sich gekümmert
hätten als Koalition hätten sie mit
denen gesprochen wann die kommunale
wärmeplanung gemacht haben erst die
kommunale wärmeplanung erst beschließen
wenn diese fertig ist dann geht man die
nächsten Schritte wenigstens
gleichzeitig hätte man das machen müssen
und verabschieden können das haben wir
Ihnen bereits bei der Einbringung klar
gesagt das ist schon Monate her sie
haben nichts bei der Kommunalwahlen
vorangebracht und das ist der
Grundfehler bei ihnen sie machen den
zweiten Schritt vom ersten und wundern
sich dass sie schief geht
sie haben die Möglichkeit zu erwidern
Geta Kollege die kommunalen
Spitzenverbände haben das Vorgehen zu
Recht begrüßt und dieser Weg der ist
praktikabel zum ersten ersten wird
beides in Kraft treten und wir kriegen
das Miteinander gemeinsam hin herzlichen
Dank
das Wort hat der Abgeordnete Steffen
Portrait für die afd-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren Frau Hubert ja
wir kriegen das hin aber nicht in Ihrem
Sinne sondern wir kriegen das hin dass
der Wohlstand aus Deutschland
verschwindet leider und Herr Spahn was
erzählen warum streuen Sie den Leuten
Sand in die Augen sie wollen dieses
Gesetz auch gar nicht abschaffen Frau
von der Leyen willst doch gerade auf
EU-Ebene einführen also freuen sie den
Leuten bitte nicht Sand ins in die Augen
und Herr dürr von der FDP wie kommen Sie
darauf dass dieses Gesetz mag Wirtschaft
sei
Marktwirtschaft ist nicht verbieten
dieses Gesetz will verbieten verbieten
ist Planwirtschaft Marktwirtschaft ist
ermöglichen hätte aber leider ist ja die
Marktwirtschaft aus dem Programm der FDP
verschwunden und das bedauere ich
zutiefst auch als ehemaliger FDP da und
er habe ich also sie prahlen hier mit
hohen Subventionen und das sind aber das
nichts anderes als dass sie als das Geld
was sie vorher den Leuten aus der Tasche
gezogen haben und das ist natürlich eine
perverse Einstellung und das zu loben
dann und da hilft auch ja kein Vortrag
auf Kinderbuch Niveau das bleibt und ist
pervers den Leuten das Geld zu erziehen
um es dann gönnerhaft wieder zu
verteilen
das Motto das Motto dieses Gesetzes
lautet 321 nicht mehr deins Ölheizung
Gasheizung eigenes Häuschen 3:1 nicht
mehr deins 30 der 40 Millionen deutschen
Haushalte Heizen mit Öl und Gas sie
werden nun direkt oder indirekt als
Mieter enteignet und es werden ja nicht
nur Heizung verboten nein die Menschen
sollen gezwungen werden Geld für
unsinnige Wärmedämmungen auszugeben und
diese irrsinnigen Kosten werden oftmals
nicht durch eingesparte Energiekosten
kompensiert werden das heißt die
Eigenheimbesitzer und Mieter werden um
ihr Erspartes gebracht und unsozial
abgezockt das ist eine Politik der
sozialen Kälte das ist ein
Frontalangriff auf Eigentums und
Freiheitsrechte der Bürger das ist einer
der größten Sabotage Akte in Bestehen
der Bundesrepublik
die Wärmepumpen Sparte von Viessmann ist
in die USA verkauft worden die Links
grüne Ampel zwingt uns nun faktisch zum
Kauf von Wärmepumpen und dann fließt das
Geld in die USA
das hat methode wir müssen unser Geld
auch für teures lng-gas in die USA
überweisen wir transferieren mit den
hohen Energiepreisen Arbeitsplätze in
USA und auch nach China die Links grüne
Bundesregierung gibt die soziale
Marktwirtschaft auf und führt uns in die
Mangelwirtschaft dazu lässt sie die
Energie und Lebensmittelpreise steigen
und verknappt Wohnraum
anschließend verteilt sie gönnerhaft mit
Subventionen was steckt nun dahinter
der unabhängige Bürger war schon immer
das Feindbild linker Ideologie den
Bürger den Bürger wird die finanzielle
Freiheit genommen ihre Abhängigkeit vom
Staat steigt der Mittelstand der wird
geschrumpft
unabhängigheit per Du immer mehr
Unternehmen hängen am Tropf von
Subventionen immer mehr Bürger von dem
von
transferzahlung und dazu passt eben auch
der Spruch der
transformationsfanatiker wir werden
nichts besitzen aber glücklich sein nein
meine Damen und Herren nein meine Damen
und Herren
die afd-regierung wird dieses Gesetz
beenden und diesen Raubzug beenden
vielen Dank
das Wort hat Dr Lukas Köhler für die
fdp-frakt
Ion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das Gesetz hat
seinen ursprünglichen Schrecken verloren
jetzt kann es im September im Bundestag
verabschiedet werden
auch wenn die politische Debatte geprägt
war von Ideologie und der Ablehnung
privaten Eigentums wenn diese
nervenaufreibend war das Ergebnis ist
das was zählt und ich glaube da hat Herr
Warnecke völlig recht sie haben ja
gerade noch mal gefragt was sagt denn
der Herr Warnecke der Chef von Haus und
Grund der dieses Gesetz erst massiv
abgelehnt hat in seinem ursprünglichen
Form was sagt er denn genau das sind
seine Worte er sagt dieses Gesetz ist
jetzt gut geworden es kann und sollte
jetzt abgeschlossen werden und das tun
wir heute und zwar mit den richtigen
Änderungen wir haben dafür gesorgt dass
das Ergebnis gut ist wir haben gemeinsam
in diesem Haus dafür gesorgt dass erst
der Staat liefern muss und das ist eine
Idee auf die sie gar nicht gekommen sind
Liebe Union erst muss der Staat sagen
was vor Ort gebaut wird erst muss der
Staat sagen muss die Kommune sagen hier
kommt Fernwärme hier kommt Wasserstoff
oder eben auch beides nicht hin und dann
kann der Bürger frei und das ist wichtig
frei
entscheiden was er bei sich zu Hause
einbaut das ist die Überzeugung das ist
richtig das überfordert die Menschen
nicht
und das ist es was wir umgesetzt haben
wir haben dafür gesorgt dass Holz das
Gas sogar das Öl Liebe Union wieder
genutzt werden kann und dass das in
Zukunft klimaneutral geschehen kann und
geschehen muss weil natürlich haben wir
den Verantwortung für dieses Land und
natürlich haben wir eine Verantwortung
dafür dass wir Klimaschutz sinnvoll
umsetzen müssen
Sie eine Frage oder Bemerkung des
Abgeordneten Hoffmann
was kritisieren sie denn hier was ist
denn das große Problem sie werfen dem
Hause von Robert Habeck vor dass es zu
spät darauf geantwortet hat wie viel CO2
eingespart werden die Absurdität der
Frage steht doch schon im Raum Liebe
Union ich dachte sie sind eine Partei
der Marktwirtschaft ich dachte das
Konzept der Union basiert auf dem CO2
Handel ich dachte sie wollen den
Emissionshandel in den Vordergrund
stellen beim Emissionshandel ist es
völlig egal wie die einzelne
heizungsauslager aussieht weil wir
missionshandel geht es darum dass der
Deckel absinkt und dass diese
Zertifikate in der Marktwirtschaft sind
für verteilt werden sie zeigen doch dass
sie gar keine Ahnung davon haben was sie
in der Klimapolitik wollen sie zeigen
dass sie irgendwie Planwirtschaft wollen
und dann doch in die missionshandel
entscheiden sich doch mal was der
richtige Weg ist dann werfen Sie uns vor
es wäre unparlamentarisch dieses Gesetz
ist im Parlament verändert worden das
ist das parlamentarische verwandeln das
ist hier verändert worden und wir führen
hier eine Debatte sie haben doch gegen
diese Debatte gefragt und gesagt das
funktioniert nicht jetzt haben
wir haben nichts gesehen und das ist
doch das Problem am Ende des Tages
debattieren wir hier darüber wie es
weitergeht mit diesem Gesetz und das ist
sicherlich nicht das letzte Gesetz weil
wir natürlich kommt als nächstes die
kommunale wärmeplanung und die ist schon
durch die Regierung und die werden wir
natürlich gemeinsam mit dem gehe gehen
in Kraft treten lassen aber es kommen
wir noch weitere Sachen und lieber
Kollege sparen sie haben hier gerade
reingebrüllt dass wir Unsinn verhindern
das haben wir mit diesem Gesetz vertan
ich erwarte von Ihnen das gleiche jetzt
gehen Sie mal nach Brüssel gehen sie zu
Ursula von der Leyen und sagen sie dass
der Unsinn der der aus Brüssel kommt das
größte nächste Problem ist dass Sie hier
alles konservieren was wir hier
behandelt haben was wir hier beschließen
werden das ist das Problem
das war erwarte ich von Manfred weder
Weber aus Bayern dass er mal sagt liebe
Ursula von alleine hier so geht das
nicht weiter das ist der Erwartung die
wir an die Union formulieren und das ist
die Erwartung die wir auch in Europa
haben dieses Gesetz ist gut geworden das
Ergebnis zählt ich kann gar nicht immer
wiederholen vielen Dank
Pension hat der Abgeordnete René
Bachmann das Wort
lieber Kollege Dr Becker
und liebe Kollegen von der Lukas
Köhler Entschuldigung liebe Kollegen von
der FDP wir sind uns einig darüber dass
dieses Gesetz der Verringerung des
CO2-Ausstoßes dienen soll jetzt ist für
mich die große Frage und da hätte ich
ganz gerne Antwort drauf wenn wir quasi
die dämpfstoffe und auch die Heizung
erstmal bauen müssen wird dabei CO2
ausgestoßen ist das richtig
wie wollen wir wie wollen wir dann
wie soll das dann geregelt werden dass
wir in diesem Fall irgendwo CO2
einsparen also die Einsparung bräuchte
ein Vielfaches an Jahren um überhaupt
diesen Effekt zu erzielen also ist das
doch Augenwischerei was sie hier
durchführen danke
lieber Kollege
die das Niveau der Frage wir können
gerne ich kann gerne ihnen noch mal ein
vertieftes Seminar wie das mit der
CO2-Einsparung Vertrieb geht vorstellen
und Ihnen das halten das mache ich jetzt
nicht das Gesetz sorgt dafür dass nicht
eine einzige Heizung rausgerissen werden
muss wie Herr Warnecke richtiger wer
sagt es greift ja nicht im privates
Eigentum ein sie können sich also selber
entscheiden was sie bauen aber da
wichtige Punkt beim Klimaschutz ist
nicht die einzelne Maßnahme sondern was
wichtige beim Klimaschutz ist dass wir
ein gesamtdeckel haben über den
Emissionshandel dafür sorgen dass der
jährlich sind auf ein CO2-neutrales
Niveau runterkommt dass wir dann dazu
noch negative Emissionen über die
Speicherung CO2 zum Beispiel in der
Landwirtschaft sorgen das sind die
wichtigen Ansatzpunkte einzelne
Detailsteuerung wird ihnen nichts
bringen weil sie nie besser sein können
als Bürger und Markt weil die gemeinsam
dafür sorgen dass wir Klimaschutz
organisieren und deswegen sorgt dieses
Gesetz an der entscheidende Stelle dafür
dass wir die Dinge zusammenbringen denn
es gibt eine Entscheidung die mit dem
Staat nicht abnehmen kann wie die
Infrastrukturen stark gebaut wird das
ist die wichtigste und wesentlichste
Aufgabe des Staates der Staat muss sagen
wie es funktionieren soll und das macht
der Staat darüber dass die Kommune ihre
wärmeplanung vorliegt und das ist der
Grund warum auch hier mit CO2 eingespart
wird
das Wort hat der Kollege Thomas Heilmann
für die cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
liebe der Bundesminister Harbeck sie
haben recht es ist eine gesellschaftlich
sehr schwierige Debatte und deswegen
sind wir natürlich auch als Union
gefordert aber ich bitte doch mal sehr
um Verständnis dass dieses Gesetz ein
Musterbeispiel dafür ist wie die
Opposition blockiert und gerade nicht
eingebunden
wurden
die Reaktionen auf der ampelseite und
von Ihnen Herr Köhler eben lässt mich
ehrlich gesagt Kopfschütteln zurück sie
haben gesagt Herr Köhler überhaupt
eigentlich
da hinten sie haben vorhin eben gesagt
es sei ein Musterbeispiel ein
parlamentarischen Verfahren das ist eine
große Verwechslung sie haben ampelintern
sehr intensiv getagt und haben auch
viele Ampel Abgeordnete an dem Gesetz
Veränderung vorgenommen das ist mir
durchaus bewusst aber ihre Ampel interne
Meinungsbildung hat nichts mit dem
parlamentarischen Verfahren hier zu tun
was ist der wesentliche Unterschied
ich gebe sehr viel richtig zu stellen
bei Ihnen Herr Köhler sie sagen wir
können nicht nach CO2 fragen weil es
doch über den Zertifikatehandel
funktioniert nein ihr heizungsgesetz
funktioniert ja gerade nicht über den
Zertifikate Handel deswegen kann man
natürlich nach der CO2 Einsparung fragen
was ist das denn für eine Verwirrung
und dann möchte ich mal das alte von der
großen Koalition beschlossene Gebäude
Energiegesetz verteidigen und zwar die
möchte ich das Verteidigen mit dem
Ergebnis auf der Basis des damaligen
eingeführten und bis letztes Jahr
geltenden Förderkonzeptes und dieser
gesetzlichen Lage hatten wir eine
rekordeinbau von Wärmepumpen und ein
minimalen Einbau von Öl und Gasheizung
und insgesamt sehr hohe Heizungs-
Januar neu angefangen
und das Ergebnis ist ein rekordeinbau
von Öl und Gasheizung und ein Einbruch
bei Wärmepumpen
und das ist keine Verfahrensfrage
sondern das ist eine ergebnisfrage und
die richtige Antwort wäre gewesen sie
hätten zuerst das wärmeplanungsgesetz
fertig gemacht die wärmeplanung fertig
gemacht und dann darauf aufgesetzt um
dann einen besseres Ergebnis für das
Klimaschutz erzielt das ist doch die
richtige Reihenfolge und diese
Reihenfolge haben sie leider falsch
angefangen und darüber auch noch eine
wahnsinnige Verunsicherung bekommen
von der Kollege hat wirklich besondere
Begabung sehr sehr lange auf meine
Fragen zu antworten aber die Frage nicht
zu beantworten andere ich habe sie
gefragt warum hat es keine
Ausschusssitzung gegeben und sie haben
geantwortet dass sie CO2-Preise nicht
richtig finden und technologieoffenheit
ich dachte ich habe sie nach den
Ausschusssitzungen gebracht und ich habe
sie gefragt ob sie ich habe zwei Fragen
gestellt und ich habe sie gefragt ob sie
die Fragen von uns gelesen haben da sie
hat die Fragen sind falsch die Fragen
sagen ganz offen wie antworten Ihnen
nicht das ist eine Missachtung von
Artikel 20 Absatz 2 und darin sehen sie
auch genau dann sehen sie auch ganz
genau welche Positionen wir vertreten
und dann kommen Sie uns doch nicht damit
sagen es gäbe keine Positionen es ist
auch nicht so dass die Ampel mehr
kontrolliert was die Opposition sagt
sondern die andere Mehrheit muss mit
ihrer Verfahrens mehr als sicherstellen
dass es ein ordnungsgemäßes Verfahren
gibt ich will abschließend noch etwas
Positives sagen
wir haben beim Gesetz Digitalisierung
der Energiewende ein ordnungsgemäßes
Verfahren vor wenigen Wochen hier durch
durchführt wir konnten uns einbringen
sie haben das sogar gelobt warum kann
man das bei einem noch viel wichtigeren
Gesetz eigentlich nicht auch so machen
warum machen sie das anders obwohl sie
jetzt den ganzen Sommer Zeit gehabt
haben das werde ich nicht verstehen
verteidige jetzt die Rechte ihrer
Kollegen
[Applaus]
weil die Kollegin Dr Julia Verlinden
hatte nämlich ein ähnliches Problem und
hat jetzt noch exakt das Wort für eine
Minute Redezeit
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
wir können es langsam nicht mehr hören
legen Sie was vor dann können wir
darüber diskutieren so
nur mit Klimaschutz gelingt soziale
Gerechtigkeit und die fossilen Heizung
sind und waren eine Kostenfalle und im
letzten Jahr haben wir gemerkt dass das
bedeutet deswegen ist das Gebäude
Energiegesetz ein wichtiger Beitrag für
Energiesicherheit ich habe keine Lust
weiter in Zukunft energiepreisbremsen
und ähnliches beschließen zu müssen
sondern ich möchte dass die Menschen
sicher und bezahlbare Wärme haben
das Gebäude Energiegesetz ist ein
Meilenstein für den Klimaschutz und in
22 Jahren wollen auch Sie angeblich
klimaneutral sein aber das gelingt eben
nur wenn ab sofort jede neu eingebaute
Heizung klimafreundlich ist entweder
machen sie damit oder sie nennen uns
einen anderen Vorschlag aber den können
sie ja nicht mal vorlegen
17 europäische Länder haben ähnliche
Pläne oder ist längst umgesetzt es gibt
ähnliche Gesetze überall in Europa jetzt
aber frage ich mich wo war die Union in
den letzten Jahren sie waren untätig sie
haben fossile Heizungen weiter
subventioniert bis zum Ende ihrer
Regierungszeit sie haben die
Heizungskeller abhängig gemacht von
russischen erdgasimporten und sie haben
jahrelang jahrelang ein Gebäude
Energiegesetz diskutiert und nicht auf
die Reihe gekriegt
[Applaus]
nicht geschützt und jetzt sind sie noch
nicht mal bereiten VerbraucherInnen
[Applaus]
sozialer Gerechtigkeit und Klimaschutz
so werden die Aufmerksamkeit für den
nächsten Redner gleich hergestellt wird
ich wiederhole das noch mal wir sind ja
inzwischen noch ein paar mehr hier im
Rund ich werde mir die gesamte Debatte
einschließlich der dazugehörigen
Zwischenrufe sehr genau ansehen und
gegebenenfalls zugegebener Zeit auch
darauf noch einmal zurückkommen so ich
bitte jetzt aber trotzdem wieder eine
gewisse Aufmerksamkeit herzustellen und
damit zu ermöglichen dass wir in der
Debatte fortfahren aber ist auch und den
möchte ich auch gleich danken den
stenografinnen und Stenografen zu
ermöglichen tatsächlich sowohl die
Redebeiträge vom Pult geworden als auch
natürlich die entsprechenden die Debatte
benutzen inzwischen Rufe und anderes
überhaupt zur Kenntnis nehmen zu können
so nun können wir fortfahren das Wort
hat der Kollege Dr Jan Marco Luczak für
die cdu/csu-fraktion
Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren Robert Hagel hat gerade
gesagt
die Debatte über das heizungsgesetz geht
heute zu Ende die geht heute zu Ende hat
er gesagt da frage ich mich lieber Herr
Minister in welchem Land leben sie
eigentlich die Debatte wird natürlich
weitergehen dieses Gesetz das ist
gespickt von Unklarheiten das ist
gespickt mit rechts unsere Eltern alle
Experten sagen Ihnen dieses Gesetz diese
Reform da kommt sofort die nächste
hinterher und sie sprechen ja vom Ende
der Debatte das ist doch ein Wunsch
stecken die Verunsicherung der Menschen
der draußen die bleibt die ist real
nehmen Sie mal zur Kenntnis meine Damen
und Herren
das Fundament dieses Gesetzes das
Fundament dieses Gesetzes das ist
genauso brüchig wie der Zusammenhalt in
der Ampel meine Damen und Herren und
seien Sie doch mal ehrlich das ist der
eigentliche Grund wieso sie als Ampel
die inhaltliche Befassung mit diesem
Gesetz verweigern wieso sie verweigern
in die Beratung zu gehen die sind so
eine zusätzliche Ausschusssitzung
verweigert sie haben Angst dass der
erbitterte Streit die sie in den letzten
Monaten gehabt haben dass der weitergeht
sie haben Angst dass ihre Zwangsehe die
sie haben wie ein Kartenhaus
zusammenbricht und sie haben Angst dass
dieses Streit über der heizungskette
dass ihm dass die Landtagswahl geht das
ist der Grund weswegen sie das
verweigern die Debatte im Plenum meine
Damen und Herren
und wenn es noch eines Beweises bedürft
hätte dann ist es doch das was der
Bundeskanzler am Mittwoch in der General
gesagt hat wo er ein Angebot eines
deutschlandpaktes gemacht hat wo er
gerade zu einem Hilferuf an die
Opposition ausgesondert hat wo klar man
ist bis jetzt wird die Ampel ist nicht
mehr in der Lage Ihre internen Probleme
aus eigener Kraft zu lösen Scholz hat
nicht die Führungskraft um die
Fliehkräfte in der Ampel zu bändigen das
ist doch die Wahrheit über die wir heute
reden meine Damen und Herren
und die Lücken in diesem Gesetz die sind
so groß wie scheunentüre die haben wir
vor verschiedenen Rednern der Ampel
gehört dass das jetzt alles so toll sei
das ist eine Verzahnung gäbe mit der
kommunalen wärmeplanung
nein damit haben da gibt es einen
kabinettsenwurf nicht mehr wir wissen
überhaupt
[Musik]
diesen Jahres wahrscheinlich beschlossen
sie aber sagen die kommunale
Werbeplanung das ist der zentrale
Bezugspunkt für die rechtliche
verpflichtenden Maßnahmen nach diesem
Gesetz das heißt sie verlangen von uns
sie verlangen von dem Deutschen
Bundestag von allen Abgeordneten hier
dass sie heute einen Blankoscheck
unterzeichnen weil wir noch gar nicht
wissen wie die Reichweite dieses Gesetz
ist sie verkennen damit parlamentarische
Demokratie das ist eine Simulation der
parlamentarische Demokratie und nicht
weiter meine Damen und Herren
und was mich und was mich besonders
geärgert er hat wenn die Grünen Frau Dr
hier sagen sie machen hier ein Paket für
soziale Sicherheit fragen Sie mal die
Mieterinnen und Mieter in unserem Lande
was das bedeutet wenn sie nämlich bei
der Förderung hingehen und sagen alle
Vermieter die bekommen maximal die
Grundförderung 30 %. und dann sagen das
sei ja gar nicht so schlimm denn die
können das ja auf die Mieterinnen und
Mieter umlegen dann bedeutet das dass
sie die Belastung der wärmewende
einseitig auf den mieterlauf verlegt das
ist ziemlich wenn sie so argumentieren
das hat mit sozialer Sicherheit gar
nicht zu tun was ich machen mit ihrem
Förderkonzept
und deswegen und ich komme zum Schluss
und deswegen das ist der einzige Trost
den wir heute haben die Wahlperiode dies
zur Hälfte rum in zwei Jahren sind
Bundestagswahl und dann können wir
dieses Gesetz auch wieder zurücknehmen
vielen herzlichen Dank
das Wort hat Dr Nina für die SPD
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist wirklich
ein Schauspiel was hier von der
Opposition von Ihnen cdu/csu hier
aufgeführt wird und es ist wirklich
nicht würdig für diese Debatte für die
Aufgabe die wir haben und auch die
Aufgabe die wir uns in der großen
Koalition mit dem Klimaschutzgesetz
gemeinsam mit Ihnen hergestellt haben
wir haben eine Aufgabe eine
gesellschaftliche Aufgabe Wärme
bezahlbar zu machen Wärme auf fossilen
Energien basieren ist nicht bezahlbar
das wissen sie auch wir haben uns die
Aufgaben verschrieben den Umstieg auf
erneuerbare Energien mit dem
wärmeplanungsgesetz bzw jetzt mit dem
Gebäude Energiegesetz in an dieser
Stelle umzusetzen und diese Gebäude
Energiegesetz gestanden sie eine Frage
oder Bemerkung des Kollegen
bitte
Frau Kollegin sie haben jetzt etwas
gesagt was mehrere Redner der Koalition
auch vor verlinken gerade gesagt hat und
deswegen möchte ich gerne aus der
Drucksache 207923 eine Antwort des
Bundesministeriums für Wirtschaft an uns
zitieren es sagt Erdgas mit CO2-Preis
pro Kilowattstunde in 2023 16 Cent in
2035 14 Cent 40 Strom im
wärmepumpentarif 2023
33,5 Cent 2035
31,5 Cent wenn man also die Prognosen
des eigenen Ministeriums nimmt und die
sagen ihm unter allen was man
einberechnet CO2-Preise Netzentgelte
sonstige Abgaben wird das was Sie hier
immer machen sie versuchen immer Politik
zu machen mit Horror Märchen und das
klar zu sagen ja ja ja ja ja ja ja
bleiben sie mal ganz ruhig bleiben sie
mal ganz ruhig wir wollen wir wollen
klimaneutral werden wie haben wir gerade
beschrieben das Thema ist ein anderes
sie erzählen Millionen Menschen im Land
das fossile Energien nicht mehr zu
bezahlen werden während ihr eigenes
Ministerium in einer bundestagsrucksache
sogar Preise die niedriger sind als
heute für 2035 für Gas angibt hören sie
auf mit der Panik machen sie Gesetze auf
Basis von Fakten
wenn sie Prognosen einfordern dann muss
sich wissenschaftsbasiert ein
Ministerium sich so verhalten das ist
die Prognosen wiedergibt die zurzeit die
zurzeit gegeben werden können aber das
Gefährliche an diesem Prognosen ist ja
auch und das haben wir im letzten Winter
gesehen das ist eben kein Märchen ist
dass die Menschen die Energie nicht mehr
bezahlen konnten weil es eben auch etwas
gibt ein Entwicklung gibt es gibt Kriege
die sie jenseits von etwas
prognostizierbaren sind nein es hat eine
Bestandsaufnahme von Prognosen die man
heute geben kann gemacht sie können aber
nicht von den Ministerium verlangen dass
sie eine Glaskugel anschieben weil sie
das auch wieder kritisieren würden und
zu Recht sondern man kann die heutigen
Prognosen nur geben aber sie aber Sie
müssen zur Kenntnis nehmen das ist im
letzten Jahr eine Entwicklung gegeben
hat die man vielleicht nicht
prognostizieren kann in irgendwelchen
Markt geschehen die heute abbildbar sind
aber die trotzdem im in der Realität
feste verankert sind und diese Risiken
diese Risiken die darf einer Gesetze die
die Gesellschaft darf man nicht länger
diesen Risiken aufsetzen und das ist
politische Verantwortung das ist
politische Verantwortung die wir
übernehmen es ist ja auch interessant
dass sie die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion sich bei den
energiepreisbremsen die wir hier
beschlossen haben nicht angeschlossen
haben dass sie die abgelehnt haben die
200 Milliarden die wir zur Abfederung
eben dieser Energiekrise angesetzt haben
die wollten sie nicht an die Bevölkerung
geben sie haben sich nicht darüber
gekümmert die Energie bezahlbar bleibt
aber wir sind ehrlich wir machen es so
dass wir wir sind ehrlich wir sind
ehrlich wir geben einmal die
Bezahlbarkeit die sie können sich
verändern sie geben einmal die
Bezahlbarkeit die Bezahlbarkeit haben
wir einmal garantiert und wir werden
natürlich weiterhin die Menschen nicht
im Stich lassen aber dazu gehört eben
gerade dass man auf die erneuerbaren
Energien umsteigt und es auch
langfristig bezahlbar macht weil das ist
auch Wissenschaft dass die erneuerbaren
Energien die günstigste Form der
Energiegewinnung sind und genau darum
geht es
und deswegen und deswegen machen wir
hier ein Gesetz was wir im
parlamentarisch Verfahren in
entscheidenden Stellen geändert haben
und fokussiert noch mal eine erweiterte
nutzungsoption von der breiten Palette
Erneuerbaren energien-technologien jetzt
im Gesetz vorsehen wir haben zudem den
Mieterschutz gestärkt wir haben zudem
natürlich die Verzahnung mit der
kommunalwärmenplanung gemacht denn Herr
Spahn ist sie brauchen nur mal einmal
das Gesetz zu lesen Herr Lutscher hat ja
gerade noch mal aufgerufen
entschuldigung ich habe sie gerade in
der Redner Reihenfolge verwechselt Herr
lutschak es ist ja schon bemerkenswert
es wird bemängelt dass wir angeblich
nicht genug Zeit gewesen sein ich habe
schon
im Juli noch vor der Sommerpause uns
alle breit darüber reden gehört was in §
70 steht also sie haben weder bis zum 7
juli oder 5 bis zum Ausschuss noch bis
jetzt in den berühmten zwischenliegenden
Wochen ist geschafft bei diesem
Paragraph 70 anzuschauen da steht im
Paragraph 70 Absatz 8 kann ich ihn sogar
noch genauer sagen steht genau drin wie
die geltungszeiten sind das ist eben ein
Geltungsbereich dieses Gesetz ist was
wir zum ersten in Kraft setzen dieser
Geltungsbereich natürlich verknüpft wird
mit der kommunalen Werbeplanung darin
liegt die Verknüpfung und sie Leuten ist
einfach wir tun einfach so als ob das
also sie haben das Gesetz nicht gelesen
und wollen jetzt der Leuten die Leute
weiß machen dass diese Regelung nicht
existiert das ist wirklich schäbig
Kollegen schweren sie eine Frage oder
Bemerkung ist Abgeordneten gerne hat
dadurch bleibt bei der Linie die gerade
eben auch schon eingerufen wurde dass
man Klima leugnen in dieser Debatte
nicht noch zusätzliche Redezeit geben
muss
und insofern möchte ich noch mal
zurückkommen auch auf diese
verfahrenstechnischen Fragen ich finde
das bemerkenswert dass hier von ihnen
eigentlich nur eine ein großes Theater
gespielt wird nämlich es wird nur das
Verfahren im Mittelpunkt gestellt obwohl
sie genau wissen dass die
Verfahrensschritte alle eingehalten
wurden wir haben zwei Anhörungen gehabt
trotzdem unterstellen sie es hätte keine
andere gegeben sie suggerieren der
Öffentlichkeit dass der Änderungsantrag
den wir am 30 Juno vorgelegt haben dass
dieser Änderungsantrag angeblich ein
neues Gesetz gewesen wäre das
suggerieren sie und das finde ich
wirklich das ist eine Verhetzung die
hier vorgenommen wird nein das
suggerieren sie und deswegen möchte ich
hier noch mal klipp und klar sagen das
ist das Ergebnis eines parlamentarischen
Prozesses gewesen das hat
Änderungsantrag am 30.06 vorgelegt haben
der hat zwei da gab es doch mal eine
weitere Anhörung auf Ihrem Wunsch hin ja
wir haben zwei Anhörung insgesamt es
gibt keine
Anhaltspunkte dass wir dieses Verfahren
in diesem Sinne
Redezeit ist in diesem Sinne wollte ich
mich bedanken vielen Dank
ich erteile dem Abgeordneten Bernhard
das Wort zu einer Kurzintervention
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin dass sie
die zwischenintervention zulassen Frau
Kollegin Scheer ich will sie schon noch
mal fragen sie preisen ja großartig an
dass jetzt auch die wärmeplanung mit auf
den Weg gebracht wird und so weiter wir
wissen natürlich noch nicht was da drin
stehen wird aber Fakt ist doch was
machen ich habe das auch vorher in
meiner Rede schon gesagt was machen
konkrete was macht konkret jemand der
nächstes Jahr seine Heizung tauschen
muss und die wärmeplanung ist erst zwei
oder vier Jahre später fertig von seiner
Gemeinde und sie passt nicht zur
wärmeplanung dann muss er die doch
wieder rausreißen oder er musste zweite
daneben sitzen und da will ich jetzt von
ihnen der konkrete Antwort was sagen Sie
diese Menschen was wir tun mal und die
zweite Frage die ich an sie habe welchen
Sinn sie sagen doch immer Sie wollen CO2
einsparen welchen Sinn macht es den
eigentlich den Menschen da draußen die
Gasheizung zu verbieten und gleichzeitig
50 Gaskraftwerke zu bauen um den Strom
zu erzeugen damit diese Menschen
zukünftig mit dem Gas vor dem
Gaskraftwerk erzeugten Strom heizen
können welchen Sinn macht das denn
sie haben das Wort zur wiederung
legen Sie einfach da wo das mit dem
rausreißen der Heizung stehen soll es
steht nicht im Gesetz es steht nicht
dran ja und das ist auch keine Effekt
dieses Gesetzes Fake News
es geht darum dass wir den Umstieg auf
die Erneuerbaren organisieren das machen
wir mit dem Gesetz und wenn sie sich
weiterhin an dieser klimaleugnung des
Mensch gemacht und Klimawandels
beteiligen wenn sie weiterhin nach vorne
schieben dann sagen
dass sie diese Situation
ignorieren und insofern sollten Sie sich
lieber endlich mal mit den Fakten
auseinandersetzen die Fakten des
Klimawandels sind einfach klar auf dem
Tisch und es ist unerträglich dass sie
das nach wie vor in zwei verschieden
[Applaus]
en Karina Konrad für die FDP
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrter
Herr Bernhard sie werden gut dafür
bezahlt Gesetze zu lesen ich gebe Ihnen
einen Tipp Paragraph
72g da können Sie nachlesen die Antwort
auf Ihre Frage keine funktionierende
Heizung muss rausgerissen werden auch
nicht die die ab 1.12 24 angeschafft
werden und es ist schon mal wichtig dass
wir uns hier mal mit Wahrheiten befassen
diese Gesetze ist kein heilshammer
dieses Gesetz ist ein praxistaugliches
Gesetz das ist ein praxistaugliches
Gesetz dass das Eigentum schützt denn
ich und wir Freie Demokraten wir haben
Respekt vor dem Eigentum wir haben
Respekt vor der Lebensleistung von
Menschen und wir wissen wie viel Schweiß
und fleißig die eigene vier Wände
geflossen sind und das schützen wir es
ist ein praxistaugliches Gesetz weil es
Technologie offen ist und das wurde hier
schon oft gesagt und wir haben immer
gesagt die Heizung muss zum Haus passen
und nicht umgekehrt und deshalb werden
in diesem Gesetz
alle Heizungen erlaubt es ist kein
wärmepumpengesetz mehr und es ist ein
praxistaugliches Gesetz
weil es wirklich offen ist erst muss die
Kommune liefern und dann wenn die
kommunale wärmeplanung vorliegt hat man
die Sicherheit was am Ende vor Ort
funktioniert keine Heizung muss
rausgerissen werden und das werden die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger nachher auch
wirklich merken und spüren wenn sich
rausstellt dass in den nächsten Jahren
ihre Märchen die sie hier erzählt haben
mit denen sie die Menschen Angst gemacht
haben nicht zutreffen werden
meine Damen und Herren und zwar ist
wichtig und dafür haben wir gekämpft
dass die Ursprungsfassung dieses
Gesetzes verändert wird wir haben sie
vom Kopf auf die Füße gestellt und das
war wichtig denn uns ist egal
gestatten Sie eine Frage oder Bemerkung
des Abgeordneten Hilse nein denn uns
meine Damen und Herren ist es egal mit
welchem Heizungssystem Sie Ihren Beitrag
in Zukunft zum Klimaschutz leisten uns
ist es wichtig dass Sie den Beitrag zum
Klimaschutz leisten und das so dass
niemand dabei überfordert wird und dass
bei notwendigen Ersatzinvestitionen oder
bei der Entscheidung für eine neue
Heizung man sich Gedanken darüber macht
wie man seinen Beitrag leisten kann und
das ist zumutbar meine Damen und Herren
aber liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
muss auch sagen der Prozess dieses
Gesetzes war nervenaufreibend und dieses
Gesetz hat die Gesellschaft an ihre
Grenzen gebracht und dieses Gesetz
strapaziert den öffentlichen Diskurs
zwischen Wahrheit und Populismus und das
leider auch bis heute wieder bis in die
Mitte dieses Hauses hinein und es muss
vorne stehen dass wir Eigentum schützen
dass die Machbarkeit bei Gesetzgebungen
berücksichtigen werden muss und dass die
Menschen mitgenommen werden müssen und
nicht vor dem Kopf gestoßen werden und
das müssen die Lehren aus diesem Prozess
sein und das was wir heute entscheiden
ist nicht die Ursprungsfassung über die
sie gerne weiter reden würden sondern
das ist die veränderte Gesetzgebung des
Gebäude Energiegesetzes der Koalition
und das haben
und wenn man etwas kritisiert dann muss
man bessere Vorschläge machen Herr Spahn
sonst trägt man genau zu dieser
Verunsicherung und Angst bei die ich
gerade hier beschrieben habe und die zu
Recht in der auch entstanden ist und die
wir deshalb geändert haben mit der
Änderung dieses Gesetzes und deshalb
stehen wir heute und frau Präsidentin
ich komme zum Schluss ein Gesetz von dem
die Fachwelt sagt dass dieses Gesetz
jeglichen Schrecken verloren hat von dem
die Welt die Wirtschaft sagt im
wirtschaftsfreundlichen Economist das
ist weitsichtig sein
klugerweise mehr Zeit und vor Ort mehr
Freiheit bekommen und das ist richtig so
deshalb werde ich um Ihr Vertrauen und
Ihre Zustimmung zu diesem Gesetz
das Wort hat der Kollege Andreas Jung
für die CDU CSU
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich will einiges zu Recht
Rücken was von Seiten der Ampel in
dieser Debatte gesagt wurde und ich will
hier noch mehr sehr in den Mittelpunkt
stellen unser Konzept und ja wer ist
dafür entschieden ein Gesamtkonzept ein
anderen Ansatz diesem Gesetz entgegen zu
stellen der Ansatz ist falsch das ist
nicht zu retten durch Änderung an
einzelnen Paragraphen durch Drehen einen
kleinen Schräubchen es braucht ein
grundlegend anderen Ansatz für den
stehen wir
erstens es geht selbstverständlich es
geht selbstverständlich das
Klimaschutzgesetz und da steht drin
Klimaneutralität 2045
Klimaneutralität 2045 heißt
selbstverständlich klimaneutrales heizen
2045 das ist die erste Leitplanke und
ich empfehlen allen Rednerinnen und
Rednern der Ampel sparen sich ihre
kraftvollen reden zum Klimaschutzgesetz
für die nächste Woche auf da werden sie
nämlich das klimaschutzgesetzes wir
gemeinsam matthiasmus beschlossen haben
es werden sie aufhalten und entkommen
nächste Woche erst gelesen dafür auf
zweitens wir stehen wir stehen für echte
technologieoffenheit bei ihnen steht
technologieoffenheit drauf aber ist nach
wie vor keine drin die neue Heizung muss
klimafreundlich betrieben werden können
aber da fordern wir dann gleiches Recht
für alle öko-heizungen und bei ihnen
gibt es immer noch den Ballast der
Überregulierung es gibt die
bürokratischen Regeln bei den
Wärmenetzen für grüne Gase ist alles von
den Sachverständigen kreditisiert worden
das ist ein Ballast der Überregulierung
gerade beim Umbau der wärmeetzeltes
Klimaschutz nicht voranbringen ist für
Klimaschutz ab
und ja Herr Minister Habig wir stehen zu
dem Modell der co2-bepreisung wie wir es
gemeinsam in Vermittlungsausschuss große
Koalition und Grüne auf den Weg gebracht
haben mit moderatem Einstieg mit
schrittweise im aufwuchs mit der
Verknüpfung mit dem europäischen System
mit Sozialausgleich schrittweise ohne
Überforderung mit einem klaren
Preissignal fossiles Heizen wird teurer
und Klimaschutz lohnt sich auch aber
Herr Minister Habeck dass wir
eingebracht hätten und dafür stehen
würden dass der CO2-Preis 10 mal so hoch
sein soll im Jahr 2030 als heute das ist
schlicht eine Falschbehauptung die ich
Zurückweisung machen sie ihre
Hausaufgaben entwickeln sie die
Verknüpfung mit dem europäischen Konzept
legen sie legen Sie Ihr Konzepte
Rückgabe der Klimageräte vor senken Sie
die Netzentgelte und die Stromsteuer
dann wird es sozial und damit bin ich
bei der Förderung vierter Punkt wir
brauchen eine verlässliche soziale
Förderung die Ampel hat die gute
Förderung der großen Situation einmal
gekürzt im nächsten Jahr und das was sie
jetzt hier vorgelegt haben es steht ja
nicht im Gesetz der wird heute nichts
beschlossen die Regierung hat keinen
abgestimmtes Konzept sie haben es heute
in die Ressortabstimmung gegeben da
sagen die Experten das ist keine bessere
Förderung es ist eine zusätzliche
Kürzung und genau das ist der Punkt in
ihrer Koalition als geheißen es war ein
Fehler erst die Regeln zu machen und
dann die Förderung und genau das machen
Sie jetzt damit beschädigen sie die
Akzeptanz von Klimaschutz und dem
stellen wir unser Konzept gegeben
technologieoffen sozialverträglich mit
einem Konzept von Heizung wärmeetze für
Heizung und Hülle ein Gesamtkonzept
stimmen Sie unserem Gesetz zu es liegt
hier vor wir haben es ja eingebracht sie
haben hier ein ganz konkretes Modell von
uns vorliegen werden sie alle Ausschüsse
gemacht
herzlichen Dank
das Wort hat Timon gremmels für die
SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren heute ist ein guter Tag
für die Energiewende im Heizungskeller
meine sehr verehrten Damen und weil
heute klar ist es gibt
Planungssicherheit Planungssicherheit
für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
Planungssicherheit für das Handwerk und
Planungssicherheit für die
Heizungsindustrie deswegen ist das
wichtig was wir heute hier beschließen
werden
zugegeben der Weg war holprig und den
Nobelpreis für gute Gesetzgebung wird
die Ampel hierfür nicht erreichen der
Weg war holprig aber das Ziel das Gesetz
so wie es heute vorliegt ist ein gutes
Gesetz wenn man sich anguckt und ist die
Mühe macht das vor unkritisch mal zu
lesen also kritisch zu lesen was
überprüfen ob die eigene Argumente noch
gelten weil viele der Dinge die sie hier
heute angeführt haben der Platte
beziehen sich auf die ältere
Gesetzentwürfe machen sich die Mühe
lesen Sie den aktuellen Gesetzentwurf
der ist ein gutes Gesetz das auch so
verdient man sehr werden darf
und ich glaube dass wir alle in der
Debatte abrüsten sollten und Herr Doktor
wenn Sie hier allen Ernstes sagen hier
würde
palatmentarische Demokratie simuliert in
einer Zeit für unsere Demokratie unter
Druck von rechts steht finde ich das
ungeheuerlich das muss man an dieser
Stelle auch mal sagen
und so weit gehört auch
müssen wenn wir respektieren auch die
entscheidungsgrundverfassungsgericht gar
keine Frage aber die Kollegen der Union
wenn sie jetzt alle ja sagen erinnern
Sie sich an die große Koalition die wir
hatten wir hatten eine erneuerbares
Energien Gesetz gemacht und hatten noch
in der letzten Minute im Ausschuss und
Klaus Ernst hat mich noch fast rund
gemacht mündlich Änderungen vorgetragen
die wir eingearbeitet haben mündlich
eingearbeitet haben was war der
Unterschied die Grünen haben uns
kritisiert aber sie sind nicht vom
bundesverfassungsrecht gezogen also tun
sie doch nicht so als ob das in der
großen Koalition so wie der Fall gewesen
ist wir müssen uns gemeinsam darauf
verständigen künftig mehr Zeit für uns
zu nehmen für solche Dinge gemeinsam und
ist nicht die gegeneinander machen sie
versuchen kurzfristige politische
Gelände auf dem Rücken der Demokratie
und das stärkt die Rechte in diesem Haus
und das ist falsch meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren das ist absolut falsch
und zur Wahrheit gehört auch da sind sie
nun auch lang genug dabei wir haben
heute nicht nur ein Gesetz zu
beschließen sondern wir haben auch ein
Entschließungsantrag im Ausschuss
verabschiedet wo wir ganz enge
Leitplanken und Punkte aufgesetzt haben
was klar ist Richtung Werbeplanung was
klar ist Richtung Förderkonzepte lesen
Sie das meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren die sie das zu Hause verfolgen
lesen ist auch nach dann werden viele
Punkte die Union hier kritisiert werden
sich im Nebel auflösen meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren es ist weg
der nebenwirklich Listen und Sie sehen
es funktioniert und Herr Spahn ist auch
unredlich sich jetzt hier hinzustellen
und sagen es gäbe nur bis zu 30.000 €
Förderung dann müssen Sie doch mal
zuhören und zur Kenntnis nehmen dass das
Bundesprogramm effiziente Gebäude noch
mal bis zu 60.000 Förderung zusätzlich
ermöglicht insgesamt bis zu 90.000 €
Förderung das gehört zu weit dazu das
müssen ja auch anerkennen meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren und Herr
Bernhard von der AFD eigentlich
beschäftige ich mich ja mit der AFD
nicht aber die Leute hier das auch alles
spüren und ihnen vielleicht auch noch
glauben in diesem Gesetzentwurf wird
keine Gasheizung verboten sie können
sogar noch neue einbauen das einzige was
wir gemacht haben wir haben eine
Verpflichtung zu Beratung eingeführt
damit die Menschen die meinen heute noch
eine Gasheizung einzubauen nicht
übermorgen Aufwachen wegen hoher
geissbase dass Sie sicher wissen müssen
die co2-preiserhöhung kommt auch Gas für
teurer und am Ende des Tages rechnet
sich eine Gasheizung vielleicht auch gar
nicht mehr weil es so teuer ist meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren sie
können sie einbauen aber sie werden
vorher beraten und es wird klar gemacht
was da passiert meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren und ich sage Ihnen ganz
klar und deutlich nach der geg-novelle
ist vor der Kommunalwahlen Planung und
wir werden dafür sorgen mit klarer
geibelt als unsere bauministerin und der
Mehrwert in dieser Ampel das beides zum
ersten erst nächsten Jahres in Kraft
tritt ein großer Schritt Richtung
Energie werden im Heizungskeller alles
Gute zum Glück auf danke schön
das Wort hat der Abgeordnete Robert
fahren
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren so wie ich das
sehe handelt es sich beim neuen
heizungsshammergesetz um einen
großangelegten betrug unter
Vorspiegelung falscher Tatsachen nämlich
dass dieses Gesetz durch
klimaschutzberechtigt wäre
dieser Bezug fängt dabei an dass die
Ampel überhaupt keine Ahnung hat wie
viel das Gesetz die deutsche Bevölkerung
das heißt die ganzen Mieter
Hauseigentümer Wohnungseigentümer kosten
wird
Robert Habeck nannte einmal die Zahl von
130 Milliarden Euro
der Fraktionskollege der
koalitionskollege von der FDP aber
Fraktionskollege ist vielleicht gar
nicht mal so falsch von der FDP Herr
Kruse hat
2500 Milliarden Euro also das 20-fache
von Habeck berechnet was ich für
wesentlich realistische halte angesichts
der Tatsache dass es Millionen Wohnungen
und Haushalte betrifft
aber was bekommen die Deutschen für
diese Billionen teure Zwangsbeglückung
Zwangsbeglückung wer nicht mitmacht wer
keine neue Wärmedämmung einrichtet seine
Heizungsanlage richtig Austausch der
kann so viel Kredite aufnehmen die
kriegt aber am Ende gar nicht dass es
nicht bezahlen kann was bekommt man
dafür wenn man die Welt retten könnte
damit und wir alle nicht verbrennen dann
ist das vielleicht gerechtfertigt wenn
man aber von der Wahrheit ausgeht dass
der deutsche komplette co2-station
Ausstoß wenn er beendet würde nur auf
0,000028%
des CO2 Bestands in der Luft Einfluss
hat weiß man dass die Welt damit nicht
gerettet wird
als nächstes kommt die Frage was
bekommen die deutschen weiß man denn
genau bei diesem Gesetz wie viel CO2
eingespart wird beschäftigt man sich mit
den Akten stellt man fest nein
Mal waren 40 Millionen damals mal 50
Millionen CO2 und am Ende waren wir doch
sehen ist ein Gutachten
meine Damen und Herren hier geht es nur
um Abzocke und zwar ein doppelten pro
der doppelte betrug liegt vorne heute
nicht mehr gehen können zum Schluss zwei
Preise weiter gesteigert werden
hier geht es in Wahrheit sie wissen
das war ein ganz ganz einfach und eins
die zwei Minuten war gar nicht oben es
geht hier ganz einfach eins
die Enten von hunderttausende Menschen
und das Vertreiben auf ihren Wohnung ja
das darf in Deutschland nicht
stattfinden wir wollen unsere Heimat
vor allem man hört sie nicht mehr da ich
ihm das Wort entzogen habe
als voraussichtlich letzter Redner in
dieser Debatte hat nun der Kollege Kevin
Kühnert für die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist mir ein
Bedürfnis mich an die Gäste hier oben
auf den Tribünen zu richten wir sind
nicht alles so normalerweise lauft die
Diskussion hier echt ganz zivilisiert ab
überwiegend
und mit den Kollegen hier ganz rechts
außen ist es so die machen ihre ganz
eigene wärmewende die produzieren bei
ihren populistischen schäumen so viel
Prozesswärme da kann man jedem einzelnen
Wärmetauscher in den Hals zeigen da kann
man eine mittelgroße deutsche Stadt gut
mit versorgen vielen Dank auch für ihren
Beitrag dazu dass die wärmewende in
Deutschland gelegt
freut mich aber eigentlich zu was
anderem äußern und sind heute häufiger
angesprochen worden die prognostizierten
erwarteten wie auch immer Einsparungen
die sich durch das Gesetz im
Gebäudesektor ergeben bis zum Jahr 2030
das ist das wonach sie gefragt haben
mich irritiert zweierlei an ihrer
Irritation gegenüber den Zahlen die sie
erfahren haben mich irritiert einerseits
wer eine Partei die sich nicht zu schade
war in der Diskussion Leute
vorzuschicken die von einer
heizungs-stasi gesprochen haben die hier
drohen würde dass diese Partei im
Gegenzug erwartet das plötzlich aber
Detail genau der Bundesregierung bekannt
ist an welchem Tag in welchem Jahr
welcher Haushalt in Deutschland nun
genau in den nächsten 20 Jahren seine
Heizung austauschen wird das ist wenig
plausibel dass sie hier fordern
und die ganze Debatte um die Reform des
Gebäude Energiegesetzes ist ich habe von
vielen Kritikpunkten und auch Änderungen
an denen viele hier im Haus ihren Anteil
hatten getragen gewesen eine dieser
Veränderungen ist gewesen dass wir
gesagt haben erst die kommunale
wärmeplanung damit wir vor Ort wissen wo
kommt die Wärme her wie kann man sie
erzeugen wo kein Abwärme und ähnliches
noch hergeholt werden und dann wird das
Gesetz scharf gestellt das wird nun zu
Mitte 2028 überall in Deutschland der
Fall sein und zapalot da sind aber ganz
großen Sache auf der Spur das sind in
den 18 Monaten zwischen der wirksam
werden der letzten kommunalen
wärmeplanung in Deutschland und den
Beginn des Jahres 2030 oh Wunder noch
nicht der ganze heizungssektor in
Deutschland ausgetauscht worden ist ja
das spricht nicht gegen die Reform des
Gebäude Energiegesetzes sondern einfach
nur dafür dass sie nicht sonderlich gut
rechnen können wenn es darum geht ihr so
Gebäudebestand in Deutschland unsere
Ruhe angehalten sie eine Frage oder
Bemerkung des Abgeordneten brandneu
ja
ich möchte gerne über die Mieterinnen
und Mieter sprechen die mir in dieser
Debatte bislang noch zu kurz gekommen
sind mehr als die Hälfte der Menschen in
Deutschland wohnen zur Miete und auch
heute sind wieder fehlerhauptungen
erhoben worden darüber wie es sich für
Sie verhält wir sind stolz in der
SPD-Fraktion es sage ich ganz eindeutig
dass wir ein Kompromiss schließen
konnten in dieser Reform des Gebäude
Energiegesetzes die klare
Planungssicherheit für Millionen
Mieterinnen und Mieter im Land bietet
Herr bartsch hat gesagt
soll nicht den Euro mehr kosten die
Umlage bei dem heizungsaustausch und
genau das ist gewährleistet wir sind bei
50 Cent pro Quadratmeter jeder Mieter
jede Mieterin in Deutschland weiß in der
70 Quadratmeter Wohnung können nicht
mehr als 35 € umgelegt werden und die
gesamtumlage über alle anderen
Energieeffizienzmaßnahmen die es jetzt
schon gibt die steigt gar nicht an
gegenüber dem was geltende Gesetzeslage
in Deutschland ist das ist gut und die
Verbesserung die noch in Zukunft die
Verbesserung die noch in Zukunft ist
[Applaus]
ich wäre bereit aber
Kollege Kühnert gut dann halte ich jetzt
die Uhr an und verrate aber dann auch
schon da dann gleiches Recht für alle
dass die andere nicht zugelassene
Zwischenfrage jetzt dann zu einer
Kurzintervention nachher noch führt so
sie sind bereit
vielen Dank Herr Günther dass diese
Zwischenfrage zulassen dennoch um uns
liegt das Thema dass die Mieterinnen und
Mieter nicht starker belastet werden wie
sie wissen sehr stark am Herzen und wir
finden es natürlich gut dass sie
Schlimmeres verhindert haben mit einer
zweiten höheren Modernisierungsumlage
was er die Pläne und FDP waren aber was
sie jetzt verschweigen ist das ist auch
weiterhin die Möglichkeit gibt die alte
unfaire Modernisierungsumlage anzuwenden
sie dann anzuwenden wenn eben nicht nur
die Heizung ausgetauscht wird sondern
gleichzeitig auch zu dämmen was ja in
ganz vielen Fällen nötig sein wird und
dann gelten eben nicht mehr diese 50%
pro Quadratmeter sind wir schon bei 3 €
pro Quadratmeter pro Monat die
Mieterinnen und Mieter einfach nicht
mehr tragen können und ich muss es ihnen
nicht erklären denn im Wahlkampf haben
sie selber noch gesagt wir müssen ran an
die Modernisierungsumlage an die alte
jetzt sind zwei Jahre ins Land gezogen
und noch nichts ist passiert noch keine
Referenten Entwurf im neuen Mietrecht
ist da aber jetzt so zu tun wie sie sind
in der Presse tun dass die Mieterinnen
und Mieter hier vom profitieren würden
das ist einfach Augenwischerei das was
sie hier vorgelegt haben das hat mit
einer sozialen wärmewende einfach nicht
zu tun und wir bleiben dabei die
Modernisierungsumlage muss fallen denn
ansonsten ist es ein weiteres
verdrängungsinstrument von Mieterinnen
und Mietern und daran wird dieses Gesetz
auch nichts ändern es wird es sogar
weiter verschärfen
vielen Dank für Ihre Anmerkung oder
Frage Frau Ley sie haben Recht die
Reform des Gebäude Energiegesetzes löst
nicht alle bestehenden Ungerechtigkeiten
und Probleme auf dem Mietwohnungsmarkt
das wäre auch eine komische Erwartung
das hinzukriegen und das Problem was Sie
ansprechen dass benennen wir in der
Sozialdemokratie genauso wie sie aber
wir können eben auch zählen es gibt für
diese Forderungen leider in diesem
Parlament nach der vergangenen Wahl
keine Mehrheit diese Koalition mit der
wir diese Gesetzesreform hingekriegt
haben ist eine Lager übergreifende
Koalition in der ganz unterschiedliche
Perspektiven sich so wie das draußen an
jedem Stammtisch passiert über die
Fragen der Zeit auseinandersetzen und
das ist ein konnis herausgekommen ist
aber ich will ihnen sagen was wir hier
konkret besser gemacht haben für die
Mieterinnen und Mieter wir haben dafür
gesorgt dass diese 50 Cent Umlage von
der ich gesprochen habe nur dann
Anwendung finden kann und das ist
wichtig wenn die vom Staat
bereitgestellte Förderung vorher auch
tatsächlich in angesprochen genommen und
umgelegt wurde auf diese
Berechnungsgrundlage das haben wir
nämlich bis heute nicht heute sind die
MieterInnen später im Land die
Gelackmeierten bei vielen
Modernisierungsmaßnahmen weil man
einfach auf die Förderung verzichten und
das ganze der Einfachheit halber an die
verschiedenen Etagen des Wohnhauses was
man besitzt weiterreichen kann damit ist
jetzt Schluss liebe Kollegin Ley in
dieser Forderung ich kann wahrlich
nichts Schlechtes daran erkennen und es
ist übrigens auch mittlere Sicht gesehen
nicht mal eine Kostensteigerung mit den
50 Cent denn wenn man sich heute einen
Haushalt wie es ihnen ja millionenfach
gibt in Deutschland anguckt der mit
gasheizt jeder zweite tut das mit Gas
Etagenheizung oder ähnlichem wenn zahlen
die Mieterinnen und Mieter heute alleine
bei den CO2-Preis und Anteil von 10 Cent
pro Monat pro Quadratmeter wenn wir uns
also angucken 50 Cent ist künftig der
Deckel nachdem der regenerative Heizung
eingebaut wurde sobald wir in den
nächsten Jahren bei einer
vor 5 Preise sind die Kollegen wollen ja
hier anscheinend auch deutlich weiter
drüber hinaus spätestens da ist die
Amortisierung erreicht spätestens dort
hätten wir Verbrauchskosten bei den
bisherigen Heizsystem die würden
hinausgehen über das was wir umlegen das
was wir hier machen für Mieterinnen und
Mieter das ist in den nächsten Jahren
Leuten Neutralität und in vielen Fällen
sogar darüber hinaus und da sind wir
stolz drauf das ist ein soziales Angebot
was wir hier mal konkret machen für die
Situation im Land
deutlich geworden ist in dieser Debatte
den letzten Monaten aber auch und das
soll nicht verschwiegen werden die Zeit
ist vorbei das kann man uns auch alle
merken für die nächsten Wahlkämpfe die
Zeit ist vorbei in den klimapolitischer
Auseinandersetzungen vordergründig über
Jahreszahlen und die Limbo Stangen die
man sich dabei hinhält ausgeführt worden
sind es geht um die konkreten Konzepte
und es geht um die Beantwortung der
sozialen Frage und daher muss die Lehre
für alle Beteiligten Demokraten und
Demokraten aus dieser Debatte sein wer
vom Klima spricht der darf über die
soziale Gerechtigkeit nicht schweigen
ich kann für meine Fraktion sagen wir
werden darüber nicht schweigen wenn es
um Löhne im Land geht wenn es um die
angemessene Anpassung von Sozialleistung
für die Ärmsten im Land geht wenn es um
vergabegesetze geht und gerechte
Besteuerung von besonders hohen
Einkommen und Vermögen darüber werden
wir nicht schweigen denn nur so schaffen
wir es auch wirklich 20 45 Klammer zu
sein danke Ihnen und freue mich dass wir
endlich einen Punkt setzen
ich
erteile dem Abgeordneten Brandner das
Wort zu einer kurzen
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin das ist ja
doch noch geklappt hat dann der Werte
Kollege Kühnert ist ja recht sportlich
eingestiegen in seine geschwätzige rede
mit so einem Frontalangriff auf die AFD
die sehr viel heiße Luft produzieren
sollen ich muss Ihnen sagen Herr kühn
hat wir von der AFD haben überhaupt gar
kein Problem zu beruflich erfolgreichen
Persönlichkeiten aufzublicken und wir
lernen gerade von Leuten die beruflich
erfolgreich sind die Studienabschlüsse
vorweisen können die auch wirtschaftlich
erfolgreich sind lernen wir gerne viel
dazu jetzt kann man von Kollegen Falle
halten was man will aber wenn ich in
seiner Vita Blätter finde ich da zwei
Abschlüsse er war Steuerberater ist
Rechtsanwalt mit zwei Staatsexamen auch
das muss ich sagen ist nicht gerade
peinlich das ist meine konkrete meine
konkrete Frage an Sie Herr Kühnert wenn
ich ihnen wenn ich ihn Kirschen als
volkshandbuch schaue lese ich dass sie
seit 14 Jahren Publizistik und
Kommunikationswissenschaften studieren
und dann darauf gesattelt haben vor
sieben Jahren das Studium der
Politikwissenschaft an irgendeiner
FernUniversität
können Sie uns allen hier im Raum die
zuschauen auf den Tribünen und den
Menschen die Millionen Menschen an den
Bildschirm vielleicht mal ganz kurz
erklären was sie in ihrem Leben schon
geleistet haben welche Berufsabschlüsse
sie haben und welche Studienabschlüsse
sie vorweisen können vielen Dank
sie haben das Wort zu einer Erwiderung
Herr Brantner diese erhellende Frage für
den Verlauf der Diskussion möchte ich
gerne wie folgt beantworten meine
Legitimationen in diesem Parlament zu
sitzen ergibt sich daraus dass die
Mehrheit der Wählerinnen und Wähler in
meinem Wahlkreis hier in Berlin
Tempelhof-Schöneberg mir bei der
Bundestagswahl 2021 die Stimme gegeben
haben ein Wahlkreis in dem mehr als 80%
der Menschen zur Miete Leben einem Thema
zu dem ich hier an diesem Punkt
gesprochen habe diese Menschen haben
mich gewählt damit ich für ihre
Interessen als Mieterinnen und Mieter
für den Schutz vor übergewöhnlichen
Mieterhöhung Umlagen und andere mehr
Kämpfe das tue ich hier dafür haben sie
mir einen Mandat gegeben und da werde
ich mich von ihnen noch überhaupt nicht
aus der Reserve locken lassen und
außerdem
und außerdem habe ich noch was im
Angebot für die Wählerinnen und Wähler
in meinem Wahlkreis und darüber hinaus
auch die die mich nicht gewählt haben
ich gehöre zu der Mehrheit der
Kolleginnen und Kollegen hier im Haus
die für die Verteidigung unserer
Demokratie von innen heraustritt und
deswegen biete ich Ihnen und Ihren
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Stirn wo
immer es geht danke dass du mir die
Möglichkeit gegeben haben das noch mal
zu sagen
ich schließe die Aussprache
wir kommen zur Abstimmung über den von
der Bundesregierung eingebrachten
Gesetzentwurf zur Änderung des Gebäude
Energiegesetzes zur Änderung der
Heizkostenverordnung und zur Änderung
der kehr- und überprüfungsordnung es
liegen mir mehrere Erklärungen zur
Abstimmung nach Paragraph 31 unserer
Geschäftsordnung vor entsprechender
Geschäftsordnung nehmen wir diese zu
Protokoll der Ausschuss für Klimaschutz
und Energie empfiehlt und der Buchstabe
a seiner Beschlussempfehlung auf
Drucksache
7619 den Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung auf Drucksache
6.875 in der ausschussfassung anzunehmen
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf in der ausschussfassung
zustimmen wollen um das Handzeichen
danke wer stimmt dagegen
danke wer enthält sich
offensichtlich niemand der Gesetzentwurf
ist damit in zweiter Beratung mit den
Stimmen der koalitionsfraktion gegen die
Stimmen der
Oppositionsfraktionen angenommen
dritte Beratung und
Schlussabstimmung es ist namentliche
Abstimmung verlangt ich gebe Ihnen einen
kurzen Hinweis zum weiteren
Abstimmungsverfahren
zunächst bitte ich die Abgeordneten im
Saal nach Eröffnung der namentlichen
Abstimmung noch kurz für weitere
einfache Abstimmungen hier zu bleiben
nach Schließung der ersten namentlichen
Abstimmung also in circa 20 Minuten
werde ich unmittelbar die zweite
namentliche Abstimmung eröffnet noch
während dieser zweiten namentlichen
Abstimmung verkünde ich schon das
Ergebnis der ersten namentlichen
Abstimmung im Falle der Annahme des
Gesetzentwurfs Folgen sofort drei
einfache Abstimmungen über die Ausschuss
Entschließung sowie die beiden
Entschließungsanträge daher bitte ich
sie nach ihren Stimmabgaben jeweils in
den Plenarsaal zurückzukehren
sie haben zur Abgabe ihrer Stimme nach
Eröffnung der Abstimmung 20 Minuten Zeit
ich sehe die schriftführerinnen und
Schriftführer haben ihre Plätze
eingenommen
ich eröffne die namentliche
Schlussabstimmung die abstimmungsurnen
werden um 14 Uhr
geschlossen das bevorstehende Ende der
namentlichen Abstimmung wird Ihnen
rechtzeitig bekannt gegeben
wir setzen die Abstimmungen fort
Tagesordnungspunkt 4b
Abstimmung über die Beschlussempfehlung
des Ausschusses für Klimaschutz und
Energie zu dem Antrag der Fraktion der
AFD mit dem Titel
Diversifizierung von
gebäudeheizungsarten erhalten durch
vielfältige Heizsysteme die
Widerstandsfähigkeit der Wärmeerzeugung
in
[Musik]